this is Jocko podcast number 198 with
David Burke and me Jocko Willick good
evening David good evening and David is
back on the podcast because echo is well
he's still on vacation and we are
continuing the thread that we did on the
last podcast with Andrew Paul the last
podcast we discussed a German Field
Manual called trooping theorem which
means leading troops and I mentioned the
American version of that document
it's called Field Service regulations FM
100 TAC 5 and the 1 and this is a little
bit it's not that important but I'm
gonna bring it up later the one that
we're going to talk about was published
in 1941 so prior to the entry of us into
World War two and they plagiarized
heavily from the troop and theorem but
there are enough differences in here
that it does merit its own review so
we're gonna look at it we're gonna
explore leadership
once again Dave are you ready I'm ready
alright let's go to Field Service
regulations FM 100 TAC 5 there's
actually a little intro section in here
and it goes like this preface on 22 May
1941 the War Department published a new
version of FM 105 operations this manual
superseded that superseded a tentative
1939 version which I actually have not
seen I'll have to dig that one up
the most recent official edition had
been the field service regulations dated
1923 the army of 1941 desperately needed
an up-to-date doctrinal guidance the
world was already engulfed in war and
the United States had begun to mobilize
thus the army was
eight times larger than had been in 1939
that's two years 1939 to 1941 you want
to talk you know you and I work with
companies now and we're growing a lot
we're in a growth phase eight times
bigger in two years and we're not
talking about a small organ it's one
thing to go from you know two people to
16 hey we're eight times bigger but to
go from whatever a few hundred thousand
to over a million that's serious
growth so continuing moreover it had
also embarked on a modernization program
that affected virtually every facet of
military activity the addition the 1941
addition of FM 100 TAC 5 encapsulates
the state of army doctrine on the eve of
America's entry into World War two the
1941 version of FM 100 TAC 5 has long
been recognized as a classic piece of
doctrine writing remarkable for its
clarity of concept and prose now come on
folks
we can't give you that much credit we
just read the German version and we know
that we know where you're getting this
from so that's that's a little bit of a
bold statement they're coming from from
this preface it also has valuable
historical it is also a valuable
historical artifact preserving as it
does the doctrinal thought of the army
at a critical juncture in history and
this is signed by Christopher R gable
PhD historian combat studies institute
US Army command and General Staff
College do you go to War College no I
went to Johns Hopkins instead oh wait
what do they call you that's right ideal
day jack and what did you study there
international public policy how long was
it how long was the school about 18
months so I was on an academic
fellowship so I was basically civilian
got a master's degree and started
working on a second degree while I was
there what was the second degree that
you started working on MBA okay the
policy what were you doing yeah so
really what that was about is is the the
reason why the Marine Corps sent me to
do that is that when I that was gonna go
to the joints to have to help formulate
how we how we relate to other countries
and the security that goes along with
that and the relationships we have with
other countries is actually pretty
important a lot of those lessons came
from World War two and you know this
isolationist mindset didn't help us in
the beginning and had a foreign policy
that helps the country create security
around the world really who are the
professor's probably the the most
prominent professor there was Elliot
Cohen he's now the Dean at Zeiss but he
ran the Strategic Studies department
that I was there and then John
McLaughlin who was the former acting
director of the CIA so some pretty
amazing guys there some pretty great
access to some really smart folks that
have spent their careers in
international international arena yeah
that's kind of a very legit so no I
didn't go to war College good deal Dave
coming in hot all right now I will say
that the troop interfering
has a much better kick off much better
kick off then then the in this one then
the field right field service
regulations but we're gonna jump in
here's where I'm gonna pick it up the
the in fact this this one is so
unethical now I kind of have to it
starts off with with just kind of a blah
blah Field Service regulations it's just
yeah here's what it says feel FM 100.5
Field Service regulations Operations is
published for the information and
guidance of all concerned
it contains the doctrines of leading
troops in combat
and tactics of the combined-arms and
constitutes the basis of instruction of
all arms and services for field service
okay that's not bad this is actually
decent
while the fundamental doctrines of
combat operations are neither numerous
nor complex their application is
sometimes difficult I think we call that
simple not easy that is simple not easy
100 percent knowledge of these doctrines
and experience in the application
provide all commanders a firm basis of
action in a particular situation so
let's think about this this reminds me
of what mattis says you know Madison's
like I I'm not gonna get surprised on
the battlefield because I've read
something close to it I've read
something closer it's something I can
relate to it so knowledge of these
doctrines and experience in their
application provide all commanders a
firm basis for action in a particular
situation this knowledge and experience
enable the commander to utilize the
flexible organization with which he is
provided to group his forces into task
units most suitable for the
accomplishment of his mission now we get
what that's saying and it's pretty cool
to say it's also it's also very verbose
right hey you got a task organized
sometimes you gotta have a flexible
organization yes definitely it goes on
and this is where we get we start
getting a little bit a little bit of
fire going here set rules and methods
must be avoided that is probably the
last thing that someone would think
about the military right set rules and
methods must be avoided and I'll say I
actually think that's a little bit of a
strong statement like you actually have
to have standard operating procedures
you have to have some rules in place I
think maybe that's the kind of statement
where you're making it because the the
common practice is to follow set rules
so strictly and I'll give you another
example so you know we talked about
humility all the time we talk about
humility all the time even though
confidence is an equally important trait
for a leader to have why aren't we
running around telling people to be
confident all the time it's because 98
the time the issue is not people are
lacked confidence 98% of the time it's
that they lack humility so that's why we
end up talking about that all the time
hey you got to be humble you got to be
humble because who ends up in leadership
positions right does somebody that's
afraid to step up and isn't confident
they don't end up in leadership
positions so over years if we're dealing
with the CEO of a company or we're
dealing with a unit commander in the
military or a team leader in any
organization they got their four years
of being confident for sure
that's how they ended up there so and it
worked for him and that only exacerbates
and and magnifies their confidence which
is good but when they get to a point
where all of a sudden they start
believing their own their own hype and
that's where it becomes a problem so 98%
of the time the problem that we're
dealing with isn't a lack of well is it
a lack of confidence it's a lack
humility now where this changes is when
we're dealing with there's like a young
junior officer that feels like they're
insecure they don't really know what
they should do and they need to say they
need they need to have confidence right
yeah and the confidence that they
actually need is the confidence to say
hey you know what
sergeant or hey you know what Foreman on
a job site I don't really know how to do
this can you guide me through it that's
the only confidence I need they don't
know didn't know how to do the actual
thing yeah they just need to they just
need to have the confidence that they
can say I don't get it
and it won't undermine their credibility
as a leader to admit that they don't
know what to do no doesn't undermine it
at all so what they're saying here is
you think about these military folks
that are always following the rules
that's kind of the that's the lean
that's the tendency the tendency is
military guy you got told to do
something you're gonna do it so they're
what they're saying is leaning getting
you pulling back the other direction a
little bit harder to balance the the
dichotomy a little bit is set rules and
methods must be avoided and then it
continues they limit imagination and
initiative which are so important in the
successful prosecution of war
they provide the enemy a fixed pattern
of operations which he can more easily
counter yeah which he can exploit right
yeah yeah so you're doing the same thing
over and over again cool watch this
we'll be waiting for you and and and now
we're get to the point where I was kind
of like well what this what this book
starts off with is basically you know
you know you get a legal document and it
starts off with the definition of all
the terms that's what this starts off
with theater of war comprises this
theater of operations is that a combat
zone is this communication zone is that
a so it goes through a bunch of sort of
tactical terms which is which is fine I
mean they're necessary necessary but
that's kind of where this thing starts
off whereas the troop and furin starts
off with just the most legit intro
here's here's number one from the troop
infer the conduct of war is an art
depending upon free creative activity
scientifically grounded
it makes the highest demands on the
personality that's that's how that's how
that one starts off this one I'll read
because these are both numbered the same
way that's how much they ripped it off
they're both kind of every single
paragraph throughout his number this one
starts off with theater of war comprises
those areas of land sea and air which
are or may become directly involved in
the conduct of war week yeah week we
didn't want that that's not what we were
looking for so then finally in Chapter
two it starts to step up a little bit
and you're gonna start this is where
you're start hearing some of the same
stuff a little bit different translated
a little bit differently here we go
no one arm wins battles the combined
action of all arms and services is
essential to success the characteristics
of each arm and service adapt it to the
performance of its special function the
higher commander coordinates and directs
the action of all exploiting their
powers to attain the ends sought so we
have to work together we have to cover
move for each other important to
remember you're not gonna win alone it's
not happening and that's also why they
say there there's no set answer for this
you don't know what armor which
component you have is going to
the one that you're gonna use and if I
sat on an SOP says in this situation you
do this every single time you're gonna
lose every single time because there is
no prescribed way to do it there's just
a framework and understanding how they
work and the art is what do I do now
yeah this is also an interesting if you
break this down to a really granular
level and this is a question that has
come up before to me you've got a person
that's naturally good at something but
they're really not naturally good at
something else what do you do well
according to this what you do is you
exploit their powers right you take
advantage of what they're good at of
course this doesn't mean you know if
I've got Dave Burke who's really good at
interacting relationships with a client
but you're horrible at paperwork
I don't assign you to be in charge of
the paperwork and not let you sorry to
client sure right but I want to make you
better
no I want to take advantage of what
you're good at
I will still say hey Dave man you've
gotta you gotta get better paperwork you
gotta get better at paperwork I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna have you running it
but you got to get better at it yeah
you're like cool
and over time you do get better at it
but it's not I'm not and then I got
someone else that's awesome at paperwork
but they're not good at communications
well I'm not gonna put them in the
client facing position I'm gonna put
them in the back room with a computer
but we are gonna work with them we're
gonna make them get up and you know talk
to some clients so that we do build a
more well-rounded team yeah for sure
you actually don't know when that person
who is weak at this one thing might need
to rely on that for organizational
success you can't you can't ignore that
yeah yeah in a CEO position I mean every
okay you've got your you got your
corpsman your medic the corpsman
obviously is the go-to guy he was
carrying the med gear and and is a
trained and incredibly advanced level
but every single person knows how to put
on tourniquet knows how to stop the
bleeding
I've he knows how to do an IV he knows
how to do a needle down decompression
like we all get that trend we can make
it happen
yep same thing with comms same thing
with everyone everybody knows how to
shoot that that pig gun everybody in the
squad everyone the platoon knows how to
do that everybody's gonna need to know
how to program the radio
yes indeed true statement all right I
now what it does now is it breaks down
every sort of arm that we're talking
about talking the arms the different no
one arm wins battles it breaks down
every arm it break down cavalry Field
Artillery Coast artillery Air Corps
engineer Signal Corps chemical warfare
because we remember this is coming off
World War one you know I'm not gonna
cover all those but I will look at
infantry because it just says a couple
things about infantry the infantry is
essentially an arm of close combat its
primary mission in the attack is to
close with the enemy and destroy your
capture him in defense to hold its
position and repel the hostile attack
infantry fights by combining fire
movement I think we call that cover move
and shock action sometimes people use
words that I need to completely embed
into my vocabulary shock action is one
of those things by fire it inflicts
losses on the enemy and neutralizes his
combat power by movement it closes with
the enemy and makes its fire more
effective by shock action it completes
the destruction of the enemy in close
combat amen
then we got a little butt here because
we all love infantry but here we go
infantry is capable of limited
independent action through the
employment of its own weapons its
offensive power decreases appreciably
when it's freedom to maneuver is limited
or when it is confronted by an organized
and defensive position that's why as
much as I love infantry you you have to
have the supporting arms and when you
capture the enemy in the combined arms
dilemma that is the glory of warfare you
know what was crazy I don't remember
when I first heard the term the combined
arms dilemma and for those either don't
know what I'm talking about it's when
the enemy or when when you are attacking
enemy from multiple different weapon
systems and no matter what they do
they're trapped there in a dilemma if
they if they move one direction they're
gonna hit with one type of weapon if
they move in another direction they're
gonna hit with another if they go to
ground and hide then the infantry is
gonna move in you're you've got them in
the combined arms dilemma this is what
it is you know that essentially it's
checkmate yeah checkmate yes exactly
anywhere else what's interesting is and
what was scary was in Ramadi the enemy
would trap coalition forces in the
combined arms dilemma so they would
initiate perhaps by dropping mortars
onto a little out station one everyone
when you're getting mortared what you
have to do is you have to get overhead
cover so now when you get overhead cover
you're basically hiding when you're
hiding then they come out with
machine-gun fire they start shooting
machine guns because they can they can
expose themselves they can start
shooting machine guns while the and the
machine guns you can you can shoulder
and shoot a machine gun very rapidly so
while that's happening now your heads
you're now you're essentially pinned
down yeah well now they come out with
the rockets because they take a little
bit longer to aim they're more you know
an RPG takes a little bit more time to
aim and you're more exposed there's back
blast to deal with so it's a little bit
harder of a weapon to handle so it takes
a little bit more time but when when
you're you're getting cover fire from a
machine gun you got that time so then in
come the Rockets now while this is
happening here comes the vehicle-borne
IEDs and and now everyone's heads are
down explosions are going off and while
this is happening a vehicle-borne IEDs
now closes in makes it through the
serpentine and and blows up inside of
one of these allow posts it happened
multiple times while we were in Ramadi
and and these little outposts these
little checkpoints these little ECP's
would be in several cases overrun yeah
the enemy also evolved while we were
there too and we started to see them
account for what they knew our normal
reaction would be ease and we understand
what a combined-arms element is
the other thing that they did that made
that situation so hard was they would
interact with the civilians so the new
our normal response if you wanted to get
on your a heavy machine guns and lay
down a base of fire there was so much
risk at injuring civilians that we had
to account for and they knew that so
they made our normal response to that so
much more difficult and they out of that
additional layer of complexity for us so
we had limited options and they took
full advantage of that and those those
of you bids as fuel Laden you know trash
trucks and things like that those things
that they did and watch them get better
accounting for what they knew we would
do made it even harder for us and and
they look they got good at that and he
was really really tough and and taking
it well again
adaptation if you recall when well when
I first got there they would do one of
those attacks at a time yeah there was a
couple days where they did to two or
three of those attacks simultaneously in
different parts the city because then
they knew hey they're gonna overwhelm
our casualty evacuation they're gonna
overwhelm our fire support they're gonna
overwhelm our QRF so they were good yeah
they were good the combined arms dilemma
it's it's a positive thing when you have
when you put somebody in it it's a
negative thing when it happens to you by
the way just I mean it's worth noting
that when you're doing jujitsu you're
looking for the same thing you're
looking to set up a triangle arm lock
sweep combined arms dilemma you've got
three things if they defend one you're
gonna catch them in the other you've got
them in checkmate that's what you're
trying to do alright now after that like
I said this whole next section it just
explains each one of the various arms
that we have you know from like I said
from cavalry to Field Artillery and boy
was I happy in Ramadi when we were able
to use field artillery that was that was
awesome I mean it was awesome - two
tanks and field artillery there's not
too many people in modern warfare that
get to do that yeah I got to control
some artillery I think it was that
to FA and they didn't we didn't get to
use him a lot but man they were so
dialed in when we called for that they
were ready to go getting to use them was
was awesome yes it was it wasn't that
common but when we did man they were so
dialed in yeah I remember the most
I remember they fired a ton of a loom we
were doing a big night operation I think
was when we were pushing into like a cop
iron yeah Springfield maybe something
yeah something like that and they just
they just put up for a solid 45 minutes
it was so epic and it was because the
because the Iraqi soldiers couldn't
didn't have night-vision so hey let's
get them what's good and be able to see
so it covers that covers it covers the
the what they call it coastal Coast
artillery Corps they cover the Air Corps
which which is pretty short and we'll
get into that later
you know pre World War two air was not a
huge element in warfare in World War two
it was in many in many cases you know
the biggest part of warfare some battles
were almost pure warfare where air
warfare I mean a lot of those naval
battles were I don't know what
percentage but a massive percentage was
air warfare the Battle of Britain the
battle Britain was 100% air warfare so
and and we'll talk about some of the
changes that happened in 1944 when they
rewrote this thing so then they talk
about the Signal Corps they talk about
the chemical Orford so they cover all
those things and and again kind of lay
out what they are and what's important
about them and then they finally get
into chapter 3 which is called
leadership
and now they get it they get some credit
right now cuz they're coming out strong
strong maybe even stronger than our
German friends over here in the troop
insurer opening line chapter three
leadership leadership is based on
knowledge of men so know you're
understanding human nature is what you
have to do if you're gonna be in
leadership position that's what we're
talking about that's what we've been
talking about that's what we talk about
all the time and that's not just
leadership in war the whole internship
everywhere that's what business
everything it is that's exactly right
it's it's it's people yes man that is
that's why when I went to college you
know we were talking about your college
where you studied policy right
I studied men I said and I did and I did
it because I was reading books and I'll
tell you I've said this before the guy
that understands human nature I think
maybe better than anyone else
Shakespeare as crazy as that sounds you
start diving into those books
he understood people there's a lot of
lessons to be learned at some point in
my life I'm gonna do every Shakespeare
play I'm gonna cover it all yeah because
there's so many lessons in each one of
those we'll get there all right
continues on and it's more we're gonna
still we're still we're still staying
strong right now man is the fundamental
instrument in war other instruments may
change but he remains relatively
constant unless his behavior and
elemental attributes are understood
gross mistakes will be made in planning
operations and in troop leading in
training the individual soldier the
essential considerations are to
integrate individuals into a group and
established for that group a high
standard of military conduct
performance of duty without destroying
the initiative of the individual yes
yeah is there much more than just be
read over and over again and how hard
the balance is for a leader to cultivate
that and to allow that to happen and how
critical that is because without either
of those
you simply cannot be successful I can't
remember if it was leaf or JP at the
muster was telling a story about how
they were watching it was life he was
out watching when he was the ops officer
at a SEAL team he was out watching the
training I was putting the guys through
training and all chaos was breaking
loose it was total mayhem it was an
urban environment and one there was no
leadership happening leaders were all
just overwhelmed and he sees me walk
over to like this young kind of pipe
hitting 'if i've who i I've been
watching him I've been tracking him and
I can see that he's he's good like he's
a good aggressive he's a natural leader
and I walk over to me he's holding like
a saw and I was like bro you know and
I'm like bro what's going on he's like
we need to get out of here I was like
make it happen
and you can see his eyes he's kind of
questioning cuz you know he's me I think
he's a one crews wonder I'm like you
make it happen and he's like okay and
just starts making the call and that
right there at some point his initiative
as an individual had been beat down
mm-hmm and as soon as it was released
into the wild he took charge and made
things happen yeah and so it is a hard
balance because you can't have this dude
just out there being rogue and trust me
some of these young seals sure you you
give them a little indication that they
can get after it and you're gonna go to
the n3 and I would see that happen to
you get some some kid that's so over the
top
that they'll just start making you know
trying to make everything happen
themselves and they'll get out of
control and that'll be bad mm-hmm
so yes this is what it is understanding
behavior understanding elemental
attributes yeah all right and then it
goes on war places a severe test on the
physical endurance and moral stamina of
the individual soldier to perform his
duties efficiently
he must not only be well equipped and
technically trained but he must also be
physically qualified to endure the
hardships of field service and be
constantly fortified by discipline based
on the high ideals of military conduct
we salute you you got it you got to keep
that there was you'd get you got to keep
that physical the physical readiness you
have to have it yeah for sure but it in
the same sentence they just say the
phrase you know the moral standard too
like it's that's a really important
thing and it's crazy how these sentences
it's kind of they're so succinct and so
straightforward but just how powerful
that comment is the physical fitness and
the moral standard you have to keep both
of those you just those two things you
know the moral stamina
yeah it's so easy for that to break down
strong men inculcated with a proper
sense of duty a conscious pride in their
unit and a feeling of mutual obligation
to their comrades and the group can
dominate and demoralize can dominate the
demoralizing influences of battle far
better than those imbued only with the
fear of punishment or disgrace
yeah there's a couple things I was I was
a thief ons podcast yesterday and we
were talking about controlling your
emotions you know he's an emotional guy
he was saying he doesn't he was saying
he's hilarious
but he was saying he doesn't have any a
moat he didn't have a very good
emotional memory so when something bad
happens he does something and he gets a
bad result and it's it's horrible
and then he'll make the same mistake you
know a week later because he just
doesn't remember and he goes oh man I'm
so stupid
and I was talking about the fact that
that's right figure out because I I I do
consciously try and control my emotions
right and I was trying to think of where
did that come from Wendy where do you
start doing this and the answer is
actually pretty straightforward I
remember as I got more senior in the
SEAL Teams well when I was junior I
remember this I see a leader lose their
temper and think that's not good that's
negative that every person in our
platoon right now is looking at this guy
like he's an idiot because they're
acting that way and then as I got older
and got into leadership positions I
realized oh if I go negative
everyone's going negative if I stay
positive everyone is staying positive
that's a big deal that's where it comes
from so then we get to this here and
this is so obvious I mean you know I was
reading this I could see your head just
nodding in affirmation that and this is
that this is the this is where there's a
there's like a split I don't know if
it's a split but there's definitely a
freezer of some kind of fissure of some
kind between people that think hey I
could if I bark orders and people fear
me I guess it's that one it's fear do
they fear me or do they respect me yeah
you do people fear me or do they love
and respect me you will get 1,000 times
better leadership from people that love
you and respect you than you will from
people that are afraid to you
yeah and that fear and intimidation you
get those short-term wins you get the
response
that we're getting suckered in yeah that
worked I got a little tactical little
tactical victory you and I talk about
this all the time
the tactical versus religion and that
that could be addictive I tell you to do
something you do it because you're
afraid of the retaliation if you don't
if I give you any resistance cool yell
at me yeah get beat brow beat me brow
beat me down and then I'll submit to
your orders cuz I just don't want to be
browbeating anymore and I go and do what
you told me to do and you walk away
going see that's right
that's how you lead yeah I want that you
V that seal you're talking about
probably what happened is he made it
aggressive decision one of his leaders
came back and crushed him for it no and
had you not been there that e5 is
thinking I actually know what to do here
to save the platoon but I'm not gonna
say anything because I don't want to get
crushed by that guy and those those
teams get wiped out in training yeah and
all yeah so if you're if you find
yourself in a situation where you feel
you need to escalate your emotions
you're wrong in 19 different ways we get
that question working with the clients
all the time and I've gotten to a point
now my answers is straightforward when
people ask how do I control my emotions
and I'm like well do you want to win
yeah I'm like then control your emotions
it's pretty much it cuz every time you
don't you lose and don't be a robot we
know that is about but that idea of like
losing your mind or losing control of
yourself the answer is always hey do you
like winning good stop doing that and
you'll win more yeah check continuing in
spite of the advances in technology the
worth of the individual man is still
decisive the open order of combat
accentuated accentuates his importance
every individual must be trained to
exploit the situation with energy and
boldness and must be imbued with the
idea that success will depend upon his
initiative and action is there any more
empowerment that a human being needs
than that right there every individual
every individual must be trained to
exploit a situation with energy and
boldness and must be imbued with the
idea that success will depend upon his
initiative and action again going back
to the muster where JP told the story of
how I was like listen everyone's gonna
be relying on you and he was like dang
and then I came up on the stage
afterwards and I said what JP doesn't
know is I told that to everybody
everyone that's what I was doing was
this right here everyone is gonna be
county you and it's the truth it's the
truth because if we're in a horrible
situation and we need fire support it's
the radio man that's gonna save us if
we're in a firefight and we need to
renew for each of the machine gunners
that are gonna save us if someone gets
wounded it's the corpsman that's gonna
save us if there's a decision that needs
to be made us the leaders that need to
that are gonna save us if we're dealing
with the IUD thread it's the EOD guys
are gonna save us everyone is that
person yeah and everyone has to be
imbued with the idea that success will
depend upon his initiative and action we
were talking about the one tag 3 a
couple months ago and I'm paraphrasing
but there's a line on there's like every
single person on your team is critical
and even the most junior person has the
ability to destroy your entire plan you
know something that was close fits right
there that was a class with quotes from
inside the one three for sure yeah
so they can win or they can lose alright
continuing the dispersion of troops in
battle caused by the influence of modern
weapons makes control more difficult
cohesion within a unit is promoted by
good leadership discipline pride in the
accomplishments and reputation of the
unit and mutual confidence and
comradeship among its members we're not
gonna be around each other it's not
happening yeah you you're on your own
out there leading troops in combat
regardless of the echelon of command
calls for cool and thoughtful leaders
with a strong feeling of great
responsibility imposed upon them extreme
ownership
every level detach cool
they must be resolute and self-reliant
in their decisions energetic and
insistent in execution and unperturbed
by the fluctuations of combat ah yes
who is I talking to I was talking to
someone lately and they're like do you
get spun up about anything and I'm like
nope what am I gonna get spun up about
nothing yeah things are gonna go bad yep
things are gonna go great yep that's the
way it's gonna be
troops are strongly influenced by the
example and conduct of their leaders
again that's the conversation I had with
with Theo yesterday a leader must have
superior knowledge that's why we study
that's why you read you know it's funny
because Andrew Paul was reading us there
with Andrew Pollan he's like it's just
ridiculous this is Andrew Paul talking
it's ridiculous that I didn't read this
when I was a young lieutenant the SEAL
Teams and we went through the whole
conversation about you talking about
getting stack of manuals at the basic
school like hey I'm gonna read them
because I have to I'm gonna memorize
whatever words are in there that I think
I'm gonna get tested on but that's not
what we're doing that's not knowledge
this is knowledge so a leader must have
superior knowledge willpower
self-confidence initiative and disregard
of self there you go a leader must have
superior knowledge willpower
self-confidence initiative and disregard
of self I liked how they had to throw
that in there mm-hmm they had to throw
that in there you know what that offsets
that offsets self-confidence it offsets
willpower eight offsets superior
knowledge cuz disregard of self is
humility right hey that's what it is
I'm not important I don't know
everything
I'm not overconfident
continuing any show of fear or
unwillingness to share danger is fatal
to leadership on the other hand a bold
and determined leader will carry his
troops with him no matter how difficult
the enterprise mutual confidence between
the leader and his men is the surest
basis of discipline now they use trust
in in the troop and theorem
they used the word trust same type of
sentence but mutual confidence and again
you know I'm not down there when Leif's
and is a platoon commander inspecting
his weapons once a day to make sure that
they're being cleaned he knows me
I know him he trusts me I trust him
that's the best form of discipline yeah
not imposed discipline but mutual
confidence that's the accountability you
talk about because I hate the
accountability is the recognition of
this needs to happen yeah and you know
that about me because our relationship
is strong enough for you to not have to
wonder if this is important and it just
gets done because you know what needs to
get done to gain this confidence the
leader must find a way to the hearts of
his men here we go isn't that kind of
crazy here we are talking about military
operation we're talking 1941 1941
depression is going on people are
starving in America and we talked about
how soft things are now well guess what
here we are 1941 we're talking about to
gain confidence the leader must find the
way to the hearts of his men this he
will do by acquiring an understanding of
their thoughts and feelings and by
showing a constant concern for their
comfort and welfare and as one of my
heroes general Mukul llaman said you you
got care about an adventure man you got
to care about your men how do they say
here show a constant concern for their
welfare a comfortable fair yeah what
does that mean you got to care about
your money
yeah and for the people listening to
this is not some sort of robotic action
- you actually have to care about your
men this is this is the authentic
authentic of this is probably more
critical than anything else because what
your men will purse will figure out if
it's not real they'll see through that
immediately I got a good idea if you
don't care about your men if you don't
care about your troops if you don't care
about your people you shouldn't be in
the leadership position right how's that
leave mm-hmm go and be a solo
entrepreneur or be be by yourself a good
commander avoid subjecting his troops to
useless hardships he guards against
dissipating their combat strength in
inconsequential actions or harassing
them through faulty staff management so
yeah can you can you go a discipline
training train hard train how you fight
all those things can you do that too
much yes you can he keeps in close touch
with all subordinate units by means of
personal visits and observation it is
essential that he know from personal
contact the mental moral and physical
state of his troops the conditions with
which they are confronted their
accomplishments their desires their
needs no your people mm-hmm the
commander should promptly extend
recognition for services well done
lend help where help is needed and give
encouragement in adversity consider it
to those whom he commands he must be
faithful and loyal to those who command
him a commander must live with his
troops and share their dangers and
privations as well as their joys and
sorrows by personal observation and
experience he will then be able to judge
their needs and combat value a commander
who unnecessarily taxes the endurance of
his troops will only penalize himself
the proper expenditure of combat
strength in proportion to the objective
to be attained when necessary to the
execution of the mission the commander
requires and receives from his unit the
the measure of sacrifice we can sum all
that up actually in by saying and this
is what we sell them you gotta build
relationships yeah and that gets back to
the to the to the comment that was made
earlier is when you violate these things
when you don't do these things for your
your your men your people
you certainly hurt them but you actually
you're hurting yourself you were you are
actually gonna be the loser in the end
of all this because you're not not doing
on things and and something that people
should understand too is when they talk
about all these different needs and
everybody on your team is different too
this isn't just some blanket I have a
platoon of 25 or a company of 50 every
person's needs are gonna be different
and you as a leader actually need to
know individually what all those are yes
and what I thought you were gonna say
that's a great point I thought you're
gonna say when you said everybody I said
all I know he's calling this when you're
doing these little maneuvers to take
care of yourself everybody notices is it
100 percent and not only that not only
do they see it but they think that you
think that they're stupid and you don't
notice what's happening yeah and you
look like the biggest idiot in the world
so you make these little maneuvers you
you you you know you have that little
that little space heater right you have
that little heater in your room whenever
else is freezing they know that yeah
they know that you set up your urinal
lager sight and it's raining and you go
into the spot where you're under the
protection of the whatever and all of a
sudden you're dry and everyone else is
wet and you think no one notices that
they notice it 100% and they actually
are looking at you thinking oh you think
we don't see you you you take you take
not just one hit for being all warm and
cozy you take two hits for being warm
and cozy and for letting everyone know
that you think they're a bunch of idiots
you think you're smart you're any idiot
yeah when you do that everybody says
but he sees it everybody sees it ah I
was we had to do security on we would
capture guys my first deployment to Iraq
we would capture guys and then we had to
we held them in detention ourselves we
like had our own little Detention
Facility
and this is just the first example that
I thought of so we would have to stay
and watch you know which sucks you know
it's whatever and though in my mind the
worst watch to take I think it was like
it was a two-hour watch and I thought 2
to 4 right 0-200 is zero 400 that's
where you know you got to wake up in the
middle of night it takes you 20 minutes
to get there you're all and then you get
get back and you get to sleep for
another hour before you gotta wake up so
the two to four is the worst worse
possible watch and I remember telling my
assistant platoon commander of like hey
right on we're taking zero two two zero
four and he's like really and I'm like
yeah and he's like check he knew exactly
why because if I'm gonna be asking
everyone else to stay awake or get up
earlier whatever we're taking the worst
possible one you know and you know you
don't need to say anything about that
and no one says hey thanks no one says
that to you but I'll tell you what if
you take the eight to ten watch so you
can go do your watch wind down go back
and sleep like a normal human being
every single person every single person
will take note of that
yep and they'll they'll log it down in
their little lock the little mental
logical engineer of your leadership
capabilities so don't be an idiot
everyone's watching yeah and you can
become that guy oh if you do it enough
you'll become that guy oh yeah and then
even when you figure it out and you
start to try to do the right thing if
you've been that guy for so long they'll
just write it like oh you're just trying
to do the right and and you can't even
see out of that oh I've got a UI be
careful you got to stay out of that hole
from the very beginning if you dig
yourself in that hole then you got to
start making like real sacrifices listen
don't worry about watch I got it all
night tonight I'm just gonna suck it up
okay you know he's doing taking one for
the team and you're gonna have to do
that like for you
before you reach level so yeah if you
think no one's noticing that they're
noticing next a spirit of unselfish
cooperation with their fellows is to be
fostered among officers and men the
strong and the capable must encourage
and lead the weak and less experienced
on such a foundation of feeling of true
comradeship will be become firmly
established and the full combat value of
the troops will be made available to the
higher commander both both of these the
troop and fearing and this both talk
about how the strong have to help the
weak that's it's an interesting concept
because it's very easy to get the
attitude of like hey that guy's sucks
he's a non-high and I'm not gonna help
ya it's real easy to take that attitude
and if you have that attitude
I remember - Officer Candidate School
there was some complaining to my drill
instructor who is an outstanding
obviously an outstanding marine you know
it was like I think we got to write
little notes to him like little little
comments you know what I mean and he got
a comment that was like you know some of
these people just shouldn't be here and
he came out and said hey should we let's
say we you know what I agree with you
we're gonna get rid of the bottom 10%
and say people like yeah and then he
goes and then you know we're gonna have
a new bottom 10% and then a new DEP
bottom 10% and then a new bottom 10% and
then the only person that's gonna
graduate from Oscar canid school is
Jessica it's like that's what that's
what it turns out - right so what you
have to do and what he was trying to say
to us was hey what you need to do your
all your whole military career you're
gonna have people that need help you
frickin help them yeah and also feeds
this myth that that you can just fire
your way to success I just get rid of
these guys and we'd be so good to go if
I could just get rid of these guys like
come on woman and business so say it all
the time we ask people hey what are the
people like in your company and most
people are hardworking and motivated in
the care and they try so one of those
people need if they're struggling they
need help that's what they need more
than anything else does some people got
to go yes there are some people got to
go
but we're just gonna cycle through 10%
all the time come on man
back to the book the combat value of a
unit is determined in great measure by
the salt by the soldierly qualities of
its leaders and members and its will to
fight outward marks of this combat value
will be found in in the setup and
appearance of the men in the condition
care and maintenance of the weapons and
equipment and in the readiness of the
unit for action superior combat value
will offset numerical inferiority
superior leadership combined with some
barrier combat value of troops
constitutes a reliable basis for success
in battle go you were writing I know you
must have something important to say
well I was actually thinking about
something that you had already said I
was gonna save her for later but it
occurred to me as you were talking about
that previous comment about these are
attributes we're talking about leaders
in combat in war and we're always making
the connection to business and things
like that here's the thing about that
last comment about helping the weak you
can teach this at any age go read the
warrior kid code these are lessons that
your five six a seven year old can start
to learn now and to understand that the
best thing you can do for the weak
person in your class or the person
struggling in your on your soccer team
or these aren't adult lessons and if
you're a leader out there and you got
kids you can start to instill this right
now and that lesson is is is not just
relevant for combat or for your platoon
or even for your company it's relevant
for everybody at every age and if you
teach it now think about the success
your kids will have in the long run you
do that anyway just making that
connection and and yeah so the warrior
kid let me see what number it is the the
the bottom line is and this is where it
gets a little bit um the warrior kid
number five the warrior kid treats
people with respect and helps out other
people whenever possible this is where
this is where everything is beautiful in
the universe everything is beautiful in
the universe because when you help other
people
you get better your team gets better but
you get better every time you teach
something you get better at it it's just
the way it works so there's like that
mutual benefit and so the idea that
hammers gonna get rid of someone this
week instead of helping them wrong
the warrior kids trained hard exercises
and eats right to be strong and healthy
and he knows how to fight so we can
stand up to bullies and protect the weak
and that's something for your kids right
there does the same exact thing they're
saying you have to protect the weak then
it helps you when you do that yeah
continuing a poorly trained unit is
likely to fail in a critical moment due
to due to demoralizing impressions
caused by unexpected events in combat
this is particularly true in the first
engagements of a unit therefore training
and discipline are of great importance
every leader must take energetic action
against indiscipline panic panic and
other disruptive forces discipline is
the main cohesive force that binds the
member the members of a unit discipline
is the main cohesive force that parts
you know is interesting I think we were
covering SLA marshals men under fire and
he was talking about when when units got
routed and wouldn't it win like mayhem
broke loose is people's our runaway it
they have documented cases where you
know the platoon leader up in the front
line goes hey runner go back and tell
headquarters we need more ammunition he
goes cool got it gets up and starts
running someone sees him run at him
running and goes oh dang we're running
and so someone else gets up and and then
next thing you know everyone is running
from one person just just seeing it
happen and and once again that's what
that's what talking with feel yesterday
the way you act as leader you got a plug
you got it you gotta act correctly if
you start to panic if you start to freak
out if you start to lose your temper if
you start to lose your mind everyone
else is going to do the same thing if
you run away everyone's good exam if you
go forward and one's gonna follow you
and yes discipline is the main cohesive
force that binds the members of the unit
together a wise and capable commander
will see that the men assigned to the
competent groups of his unit are
compatible and that the composition of
the groups is changed as little as
possible all right so I'll read that one
more time a wise and capable commander
will see that the men assigned to the
company to the component groups of this
unit are compatible right so they can
interoperate and they can change around
and that the compositions of this group
groups is changed as little as possible
so when you have little subunits keep
them together keep them together that's
they get to know each other they get to
understand each other they can read out
read each other and that's the way you
need to work you know they don't need to
freaking redevelop a relationship they
already have it when uh when task unit
bruiser went through our urban training
and we we had a bunch of strap hangers
with us well it wasn't really strap
hangers we had a bunch of other people
the EOD people some other but we
probably had an additional like 15
people with our task unit and so the the
initial reaction from from Lafe and Seth
was they put those guys you know that's
- you know that's two other squads you
know that's we don't want them in our
platoon and I was like uh know what
we're gonna do is we're going to take
one or two of them and put them in each
one of our fire teams and make them part
of our unit and you know they objected
but what happens what happens is that
those people get individual it's very
easy for a four or five man fire team to
absorb one or two people yeah hey cool
what's your name Fred cool right on
you're good hey I'm bill let let me know
here's what I wear I'm at hey here's how
we do our headcount
here's what we're looking for boom the
integration was almost immediate now we
have now when it was time to assault a
building and we we call them sections
because they weren't really fire teams
they were a little bit bigger now so I
called him section
and which is I stole from the Grom which
is the Polish special operations that I
worked a ton with my first deployment in
Baghdad they called nad sections of like
six guys I was like cool we're gonna
have sections now because we're a little
bit bigger than fire team cool and then
it was like sections two three and four
assault section one hold fast and
everyone knows what to do and you got
little micro section leaders that are
making things happen yeah that doesn't
have one you take the six new guys and
give them their own section yeah yeah
yeah no and then you take that you have
three of those right which is probably
what we would have had three sections of
people just randomly out there by the
way and those people weren't even
integrate as a unit it wasn't like it
was a separate platoon if it was a full
put another platoon of seals that would
have made some sense okay cool
we got a full know the platoon seals
they have they're broken into fire ok
cool we get it we can command that but
we have 16 15 20 rendom people that
haven't been working together cool guess
what you're about to report to a leader
in task unit bruiser this is petty
officer 2nd class get some yeah but
that's so that's what you want to do you
want to look you want to keep your team
together continuing he will provide each
group with a leader in whom its members
have confidence that's another thing
right so now you got you got the task
unit bruiser guys everyone knows that
fireteam leader they don't have to meet
Fred that guy who was at the jump team
for eight years he doesn't know he's
don't know it doesn't matter you know
Fred's get on board with the program he
wants to win he will so regulate the
interior administration of the unit's
that all groups perform the same amount
of work and enjoy the same amount of
leisure he will see that demonstrated
efficiency is promptly recognized and
rewarded he will set before all a high
standard of military conduct and apply
the same rules of discipline to all
here's a good one good morale and a
sense of unity in a command cannot be
improvised they must be thoroughly
planned and systematically promoted they
are born of just in fair treatment a
constant concern for the soldier's
welfare oh you want to build morale
there you go a constant concern for
the soldiers welfare thorough training
in basic duties comradeship among men
and pride and self-organization and
country morale is a byproduct of your
leadership good leaders have units with
good morale bad leaders don't period
yeah the Marine Corps does a damn good
job of this one don't they I mean it and
I mean the military does in general look
to him the Marine Corps is good at that
because when you're in the Marine Corps
you're in the Marine Corps that's just
the way it is the establishment and
maintenance of good morale are incumbent
upon every commander and all the marks
of good leadership which is what you've
just said and then we get to number 111
the first demand in war is decisive
action commanders inspire confidence in
their subordinates by their decisive
conduct and their ability to gain
material advantage over the enemy a
reputation for failure in a leader
destroys morale the morale of a unit is
that of its leader again that's what you
just said but hey the first demand in
war is decisive action and again it
talked about this with Andrew Paul the
ninja Paul gave a great example
you know decisive action doesn't mean
you just make the full commitment to a
decision he he gave that example of of
looking at your Google Maps oh you know
you got a you're gonna walk through the
city to a place and it's two miles away
and so you walk out of the hotel and you
look at your Google Maps and you're it
the the arrow is just spinning yeah cuz
you're not going anywhere
cool start walking take ten steps take
ten steps that thing will self-correct
because and now you'll know where you're
supposed to be going so that's that's a
decisive action sitting there not doing
anything isn't getting you anywhere and
the enemy's maneuvering on you by the
way yeah and that that flipside you
talked about is hey we want to get into
this space let's buy three buildings
whoa whoa hang on
we actually that that is overly that's
way
overly aggressive and actually isn't
what you need yeah that example was
awesome
a commander must bear in mind that
physical unfitness will undermine his
efficiency and actually surprisingly I
don't think this is in the crouppen fury
at all I don't think they talk about
physical fitness in this much clarity a
commander must bear in mind that
physical unfitness will undermine his
efficiency he owes it to the men under
his command to conserve his own Fitness
neglect renders him unable to bring a
normal mind to the solution of his
problems and reacts unfavourable on his
whole command that is that is a heavy
statement
here's the thing did you know that you
know that term fatigue will make a
coward out of any man like when you get
tired it's you start making bad
decisions and you can't maintain so
that's what this is and if you're the
better physical condition you're in the
more you'll be able to maintain for you
know people freaked out cuz I don't
sleep a lot which I'm not I don't
encourage people not to sleep a lot you
should sleep as much sleep as you need
get a bunch of sleep it's great I know
the sleep diplomat guy sleep I'm not
against that sleep but what I will say
is this like if you're in good physical
condition and you eat well you will not
need as much sleep um I'm here to tell
you like well at least I don't think you
do I was talking about with with with
Flynn Cochran the other day on being on
the road all the time and sometimes
we're on the road I flew literally to
Maine 36 hours ago and I flew back the
very next day I was on the road and and
the the best thing you can do in a
situation like we're gonna be tired is
actually good workout know for sure I
mean it's the best thing you can do and
the days that I get them like oh I'd
have to work on a 3:30 and I don't
I regretted the entire day yeah
I've never once heard you say you don't
need sleep but what the reality is is is
when you're tired the best thing you can
do is get out of bed and do something
physical yeah it's the best way to
without a doubt yeah and yeah it's
physical fitness don't neglect it that
that happens a lot of times in business
people get wrapped in the business and
if you don't make some time to stay
physically fit strategic look there's
gonna be times in business there's times
additional in front there's times in our
lives where hey man you you like I don't
I can't do my normal workouts during the
muster like we do a we do we work out
but it's not it's not my normal workout
it's a workout that takes 40 minutes not
and it's only one a day you know so
that's not normal we gotta suck it up
for the muster it's you know four or
five days of us very very work intensive
mm-hmm
but when that's over man you got to get
right back into it so people that go hey
I get it you've got some project due and
you got a week where you can only work
out for ten minutes a day eight minutes
a day twenty-eight minutes a day
whatever cool get it I get it if you
don't work out and then all of a sudden
you can develop that habit well then you
have to bear in mind that the physical
unfitness is gonna undermine your
efficiency period in the story net so
that's that closes out leadership the
next chapter is called the exercise of
command doctrines of combat chapter four
here's where we give credit good writing
solid statement the ultimate objective
of all military operations is the
destruction of the enemy's armed forces
in battle which those simple statements
like that it's interesting when we go
work with companies and no one ever
everyone is completely lost track of
what it is that they're trying to do
yeah what's your mission yep the ability
to select objectives whose attainment
contributes most decisively and quickly
to the defeat of the hostile armed
is one attribute of the able commander
what does that mean a good leader has
the ability to prioritize and execute
the most important things I'll read it
again the ability to select objectives
whose attainment contributes most
decisively and quickly to defeat the
hostile Armed Forces is one attribute of
the able commander that is prioritize
and execute you've got a pick for the
most import what they call here the the
objective whose attainment contributes
most decisively that's the most
important thing that's what you're going
to focus on prioritize and execute next
simple and direct plans and methods with
prompt and thorough execution are often
decisive in the attainment of success
that is almost verbatim from coop and
Fuhrer
almost the exact same thing you've got
to keep things simple people been saying
that forever
next unity of command obtains that unity
of effort which is essential to the
decisive application of full combat
power of the available forces unity of
effort is furthered by full cooperation
between elements of the command
so yes prioritize and execute figure out
what's most important and then cover and
move for each other as you as you
execute next through offensive action a
commander exercises his initiative
preserves his freedom of action and
imposes his will on the enemy boom there
you go what is that
offensive action being on the offense
not being on the defense think of what
it does for you as a person as a human
as a leader it exercises your initiative
preserves your freedom of action and
imposes your will on the enemy you've
got to go on offense a defensive
attitude may however be deliberately
adopted it has a temporary expedient
while awaiting an opportunity for
counter offensive action
Hey look sometimes you have to be
defensive for a minute but you better be
looking for that moment to get go back
on the offense the defensive posture is
designed to find the opportunity to go
on the defensive go on the offensive
that's why you're doing it yeah if
you're on the defense this is so clear
in jiu-jitsu if you're under defence in
jiu-jitsu and you stay on defense
you will lose eventually you're going to
get caught you can only defend so much
they're attacking they have the
initiative they have the freedom of
action they're imposing their will on
you you can defend for a little while
but eventually you're gonna get taken
you're gonna get submitted it's same in
flying and there is a comment in there
that I I think it's the describe the
freedom of movement it's the thing we
talk about all the time as the attribute
to make sure that you're doing it
correctly is can you still maneuver and
so you can't be so offensive that you no
longer can maneuver and but the ability
to maneuver in that position is what
allows you to find the opportunity to
exploit and then go on the offensive to
preserve your maneuvering room is the is
the part that you know you're balanced
in those so how do you overcome it and
in aircraft it's actually it's easy and
it happens all the time and you have the
air aircraft have potential energy or
capability and if your maneuver to get
closer or whatever you're trying to do
with another aircraft if you overdo that
and then it's your next move you don't
have any energy to turn the aircraft
you're gonna lose and that could happen
in the most powerful airplane in the
world I could be in a raptor and if I
turn it really hard and actually turn it
too hard and my energy goes from 300
knots to 100 knots and I haven't allowed
myself to kill them at that move so I
need another move on the chessboard and
there's no energy left
I literally can't maneuver and I can and
I will lose to an inferior platform so
when you're riding a bicycle if you if
you're going slow it's harder to stay
balanced and it's harder to turn is that
the same is that the same thing like
when you're in an aircraft you get a
certain amount of speed there's a point
at which and it's measured you know at
that point is where you're maneuvering
gets to a peak and then starts to
diminish and then you can no longer
maneuver based on that so yeah and
that's speed that's solely based on
speed it's exactly right or we call
potential energy you might need altitude
you would descend to get that energy
back but it's a combination of the
actual air speed the number in your
display 100
miles an hour or whatever it is and I
was altitude that you have and the
ground is the ground and so you cannot
get descend whatever your airspeed is
that's what you have left and it's we
call it potential energy but it boils
down to how much maneuvering airspeed do
you have how fast is a raptor have to be
going so it doesn't stall well that
number happens to be extremely low and
the irony in that is a lot of people
don't understand is that your minimum
controllable airspeed is a critical
component so the slower I can go and be
maneuverable is a huge advantage for me
but ever every aircraft has a limit that
if you get past whatever that number is
you let you're out of maneuvering
airspeed and you're gonna lose you have
to have the ability to maneuver no
matter what situation you're in to
include being on the defensive and
that's what they're talking about is I'm
gonna stay in this position until I see
the opportunity to go the offensive and
I'm gonna maneuver in that position what
was that standard move that you do and
you don't know what to do lift vector on
and pull point of the guy and turn until
you figure out what you need to do next
lift vector essentially where your
airplane is going in the sky and if you
don't know what to do you put your
little factor directly on your opponent
you point directly at him and you start
to maneuver towards directly towards him
that doesn't mean it's the right move
mmm it means because you don't know what
the right move is you have to be doing
something because if you sit there and
do nothing which is sort of the ultimate
defensive position is I'm just gonna
hole up and bury you're gonna die so
quickly go on the offense go on the
offense even if you're not a hundred
percent sure what to do go on the
offense the defensive posture is
actually a decision you make by design
going on the offensive if you don't know
what to do is if as long as you're
maneuvering the more training the more
reps you have the sooner you're gonna
figure out what to do the the default
aggressive mindset of going on the
offensive where doesn't that apply
hmm yeah I mean and this is something
that Andrew and I talked about you
obviously you don't just commit and
watch see what you just said you just
don't commit ignorant ly no and you
don't over commit you make the small
decisions even lift vector on and pull
even that that's it like an adjustment
but then you're a media
we you just enter the you to loop that's
your that's your ten steps down the road
to get oriented that Andrew just
described yeah and as soon as you okay
I've got it figured out now you go do
something else you got to keep that
maneuvering speed continued on the
selection by the commander of the right
time and place for offensive action is a
decisive factor in the success of the
operation numerical inferiority does not
necessarily commit a command to a
defensive attitude superior hostile
numbers may be overcome through greater
mobility better armament and equipment
more effective fire higher morale and
better leadership superior leadership
often enables a numerically inferior
force to be stronger at the point of
decisive action leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield
so legit nobility armed better armament
and equipment more effective fire higher
morale
isn't it interesting everyone would
think better armament right everyone
would think better equipment most people
would think better effective fire but
higher morale just having higher morale
is an element in achieving victory even
if you're in a numerically inferior
position a strategically defensive
mission is frequently most effectively
executed through offensive action it is
often necessary for an inferior force to
strike at an early moment in order to
secure initial advantages or to prevent
itself from being overwhelmed by a
growing superiority in hostile forces if
you run a company and you're the smaller
company that you're competing with your
competitors being defensive is it gonna
get you killed
you're gonna lose to you you're gonna
get run over by this bigger company
because they're gonna use their
resources and size to bulldoze you you
have to be poised to strike go on the
offensive the first opportunity you can
that is the right opportunity to do that
yeah it's interesting in jujitsu is the
same thing happens one of the best
things to do if you're on the defensive
is attack something and then all of a
sudden you can you can turn the tables
really really quick
if you're lucky concentration of
superior forces both on the ground and
in the air at the decisive place in time
and their employment in a decisive
direction creates conditions essential
to victory
so again this is this is prioritizing
actually what are you doing you're
concentrating your resources your people
your manpower you're concentrating
everything at the right time such
concentration requires strict economy
and the strength of forces assigned to
secondary missions what does it happen
mean if you focus on other things
if you don't prioritize and execute
you're gonna fall apart detachments
during combat are justifiable only when
the execution of tasks assigns assigned
them contributes directly to success in
the main battle so I got a little note
there never split forces I loved it when
tilt was on until was talking about he's
like yeah so I had one group in the
valley and one group in the tree line or
something like that and I was kind of
like I was all bummed out and I was all
nervous and I was all sad cuz I always
preach don't split forces and I was like
huh
I was like man I I was like I never
really liked to split forces he goes I
only did it two times yes yes yeah yeah
cuz when you well there's all kinds of
confusion that happens there but then
this is this isn't really talking about
not splitting forces what this is
talking about is if you start peeling
people off to do other things it better
really still contribute to the main
effort yep surprise must be sought
throughout the action by every means and
by every echelon of command it may be
obtained by fire as well as by movement
surprise is produced through measures
which either deny information to the
enemy or positively deceive him as to
our dispositions of movements and plans
terrain which appears to impose great
difficulties on operations may often be
utilized to gain surprise surprise is
furthered by variation in the means and
methods employed in combat and by
rapidity of execution when Brian Stann
was on he was like he loved to talk
about that operational tempo and and
that's what this is talking about in
that last sentence you know how
quickly can you execute if you can if
you can turn quickly and you can get
back out there
that's gonna that's gonna surprise the
enemy going in into Ramadi in boats that
was a terrain that knew the enemy didn't
expect the boys to come in on like
that's what's gonna happen
there was other times where guys went on
long patrols the enemy didn't think
we're gonna be out there surprise finds
the enemy in a state of mental moral or
physical unpreparedness every effort
should be made to deny him to take
effective counter measures the effective
surprise may be lost through dilatory
methods of execution to guard against
surprise requires a correct estimate of
enemy capabilities adequate security
measures effective reconnaissance and
readiness for action of all units every
unit takes the necessary measures for
its own local ground and air security
provision for the security of flanks and
rear is of special importance it also
requires humility to recognize that you
don't necessarily know exactly what your
enemy is gonna do and might want to
think that they are more capable than
you think they might be and you have to
have the ability to recognize hey they
might do something that we might not
anticipate and a humble leader doesn't
get in place and what the enemy can and
will do know they'll never attack they
never do that they would have to
wherever like that's exactly what
they're gonna do if you're not yeah
absolutely
command is the authority the sections
called command command is the authority
which an individual in the military
service lawfully exercises over
subordinates by virtue of rank or
assignment so that's what command is hey
I lawfully outrank you and therefore you
know you have to obey me then it says
this command and leadership are
inseparable whether the forces large or
small whether the functions of command
are complex are simple the commander
must be the controlling head his must be
the mastermind and from him must flow
the energy and impulse which are to
animate all under him so
that's a little bit interesting and and
then we get into this and that's when I
was talking earlier about how there's
always that that that difference between
people that think hey good leadership
means these people will just listen to
me because I I have authority over them
right and then there's people that
realize the truth which is that's not
the way you want to lead at all which we
which we'll get into here decision as to
specific course of action is
responsibility of the commander alone
while he may accept advice and
suggestions from any of his subordinates
he alone is responsible for what the
unit does or fails to do and I think
that was that's really the the crux of
what that last statement was trying to
say is like listen you're gonna have a
platoon chief a platoon sergeant
whatever a company first sergeant a a
chief operation operating officer or
chief operations officer that's going to
give you advice it's gonna help you make
decisions but if you're the boss it's on
you and at the end the idea that the the
leader the commander is responsible for
the outcome no matter what as I think
what they're getting at I mean I hear
that and there are words that I don't
like exactly the way that they say it
but I'm glad that they're making that
clear distinction that command and
leadership are two different things
command is the structure and we all
understand that military I know who my
boss is the org chart in any company
defines the CEO the CEO the the
frontline supervisor but the leadership
component a good commander not only am I
going to take advice from other people
there are times that I simply won't be
where they are and I need them to make
those decisions and lead their team and
if it ends up being wrong it's still my
responsibility and that that piece of it
I think is 100 percent sure yeah yeah
it's will dig into it a little bit more
here in a second this continues on which
is this is getting into exactly what you
were just saying a willingness to accept
personal responsibility is the foremost
trait of leadership
so we wrote an entire book about that
called extreme ownership a willingness
to accept responsibility is the foremost
trait of leadership every individual
from the highest commander to the lowest
private must always remember that
inaction and neglect of opportunities
will warrant even more severe censure
than an error of judgment in the action
taken so this is something that troop
and furin definitely hit on almost
word-for-word it's worse to not do
anything than it is to make a call and
try and execute and you have bad
judgment so those are bold statements
continues on the criterion by which a
commander judges the soundness of his
own decision is whether it will further
the intentions of the higher commander
so there you go that makes it really
easy to make decisions out of the
battlefield if you can come back to me
and say I hate jockle this is what I did
you know I know that we were trying to
push West and I had an opportunity to
get on this null I know it was outside
our limit of advance but it gave me a
really good field of fire over the West
that's why I went there and I'm like you
know what ended up not working out the
way we wanted it to but I'm glad that
you did it okay because at least you
went for it as opposed to well you know
I've I know we were going west but I
decided you know maybe it would be
smarter for us to go east and that's why
I backed my force off right you can't
just ignore the the overall commander
the overall commander in the higher
position you gotta you got to support
his intentions so as long and what that
means is for the higher commander you
gotta make sure that your intentions are
known that's why we have commander's
intent totally willingness to accept
responsibility must not manifest itself
in a disregard of orders on the basis of
a mere probability of having better
knowledge of the situation than the
higher commander the subordinate unit is
a part of a tactical team employed by
the higher commander to accomplish a
certain mission and any independence on
the part of the subordinate commander
must conform to the general plan for the
unit as a whole so that's why we have
poor
that's what decentralized command that's
why when I'm always going off about hay
for decentralized command to work you
have to make sure everyone understands
what the mission is what the goal is
what the end state is what the
parameters are that people are allowed
to work with it that's what you need to
do and that's what they're talking about
here continuing if the commander's
mission is contained in the orders which
he has received nevertheless a commander
of a subordinate unit cannot plead
absence of orders or the non receipt of
orders as an excuse for inactivity in a
situation where action is where action
on part on his part is essential or
where a change in the situation upon
which the issued orders were based
renders such orders impractical or
impossible of execution so lack of
orders lead in absence of orders lead
the I didn't know nobody told me what to
do yes and and that same responsibility
for the leader of recognizing that he
has to train his people to be able to
lead in the absence of orders is 100%
going to happen all the time
in those situations and this is so scary
especially from a military perspective
it's really scary because if this sounds
like could easily just just devolve into
total mayhem right Hey look just because
you don't have orders doesn't mean you
should sit around and do nothing and and
people there's some people that think
well I don't want my damn for some you
know corporal fireteam leader out there
making calls yes you do
you have to as long as he understands
from you what the intent is then he's
cleared hot yeah and you'll figure out
the right thing to do I had 13 guys in
my Anglican team you know money 13 and I
was thinking man this is 13 guys this is
this is a small group but this is this
is easy and when I got there immediately
immediately I think the second day I'm
there and like man I got to split these
teams up there's just too many missions
too much to do I simply can't do this as
13 people I got to do 4 here 4 here and
I split them up 9 maybe 10 of the 13
guys were on their very first deployment
and look I'll be honest with you the
first time I watched another gun truck
go off the base without me and like man
I don't like this I didn't like that but
not only was it necessary obviously he
was completely necessary because the the
the op tempo in Ramadi was just
completely out of control I could have
used 30 more people if I had them but
the reality is is that if you train them
and they actually understand what
they're there to get accomplished they
can go lead without you being there and
you need them to and they have to go do
it and yeah as a leader it is a little
hard to let that go decentralized
command you know the ultimate
culmination of these laws which is what
you want it is a little scary and it was
a little hard but you can't you can't
there's no other alternative what it
should what that fear should do that
fear should compel you to make sure that
everyone understands what the
commander's intent is make sure that
understand what the parameters are yes
make sure they understand the rules of
engagement make sure they understand
everything that's in your head that's
what it should compel you to do because
it is scary yeah and that you've done
all the other things required to get to
that I have incredibly strong
relationships they understand every
single thing I need them to understand
and they know that we have to make hard
decisions on the battlefield and
prioritize they're gonna do the ones
that greatly the most impact on the
omission return accomplished I actually
have to follow the laws of combat if I
want to get to decentralise command
check continuing on if the situation
does not permit communication with the
superior commander and the subordinate
commanders familiar with the general
plan of operations or the mission of the
whole command he should take appropriate
action and report situation as early as
practicable which is what exactly what
you guys did and what you did with them
the situations that confront a commander
at war are of infinite variety in spite
of the most careful planning and
anticipation unexpected obstacles
frictions and mistakes are common
occurrences in battle so that's right
things are gonna go wrong a commander
must school himself to regard these
events as commonplace and not permit
them to frustrate him and the
accomplishment of a mission yeah what
spins me up enough nothing nothing
everyone's gonna screw up I'm gonna
screw up you're gonna screw up the team
leader is gonna screw up the platoon
sergeants gonna screw up the platoon
commanders that's what's got any energy
who's gonna do unexpected things
that's what's gonna
and guess what's gonna happen in your
life things are gonna go wrong
the-the-the yields not gonna get closed
the kids gonna get sick the cars gonna
crap these things are gonna happen
they're going to happen it's the way
life is
no one's rolling through life not
hitting speed bumps it's not happening
don't let him throw you off now here we
go
personal conferences between the higher
commander and his subordinates who are
to execute his orders may at times be
advisable that the latter may arrive at
a correct understanding of the plans and
intentions of their superior then it
continues on commanders do not justify
their decisions to subordinates nor do
they seek the approval of subordinates
for their actions now when I read that
like the other one that we were both
kind of like yeah I'm not sure when I
read that right there I was like here's
my notes you see what they say it says
wrong I wrote that's wrong that's just
wrong I'll read it again so we know
what's wrong it starts off with
something cool hey personal conferences
between the higher commander and his
subordinates who are to execute his
orders may at times be advisable
yep you wanna meet with your people so
that the latter may arrive at the
correct understanding of the plants and
intentions of the Spirit yes meet with
your people - home what's going on but
then it says this I kind of have to
change voices for this one a little bit
commanders do not justify their
decisions to subordinates nor do they
seek the approval of their subordinates
for their actions and so I highlighted
that circled it and I wrote wrong and I
was really pissed when I read it and I
was like you know what let's see if
anything changed so I went to the 1944
manual and in 1944 that there's there
are very limited changes in this section
in fact mostly what is difference
different between 1944 and 1941 is they
have the massive sections on
power on how it's gonna be used closer
and all that stuff in the 1944 version
they completely eliminate that sentence
yeah good they completely eliminate that
sentence because guess what as a
commander you are absolutely trying to
explain your decisions to your supportin
see you want them to understand why
you're making a decision
you want them to nevermind to prove you
want them to actually just totally
embrace and love and probably hopefully
even come up with that decision
themselves there's probably some element
in there of this idea of decisiveness
and the language of probably trying to
get to something that they were thinking
about that that was clearly not
explained correctly but this idea that
you don't know your people and
explanation it is crazy it's crazy and
as a matter of fact if you can't explain
it in a way that's really compelling to
have them go oh boss got it I'm on board
you're doing it wrong you actually don't
understand it well enough and if you
have to leverage the oh you don't
understand what I'm saying okay just do
your job because I'm in charge of you I
it's just wrong
yeah period and it's it like this stood
out for me so that this is not in the
German manuals at all it's not in there
there's nothing that says anything close
to that the German manual so what that
told tell told me is that's why I
started thinking about this pull between
people that leaders that are like hey
listen to bottom line there's people cut
do tell me dude I went that's what there
was a guy in the room wonder if there's
that that guy there so hey this is 41
now I think you know a little apiece you
know hey there's this piece of this this
time that they didn't really quite get
it the 44 guys are thinking well what
have we been doing for the last three
years get rid of that because that's
crap it doesn't were exactly this room
in this room there was some poke some
rear-echelon dude that was sitting there
going hey you know the bottom line no I
understand that we want you know people
gotta understand but the bottom line is
you don't have to go and justify your
decisions to your subordinates you know
that you don't need to seek approval you
tell them what to do
and then going damn Dewar's that's the
way it's gotta be in the end you're in
charge so if they can't you know go back
and forth for a while but sooner later
you got to put your foot down yeah and
let them know who's in charge you gotta
just gotta let them have it and like you
said you can you imagine they reconvene
after three years of war and they say
you know what
who wrote who's the Pogue that wrote
that we're not gonna rewrite it or chant
it you can't just read a bit of that
sentence I wasn't sure if I wanted to we
were actually gonna cover this manual
but when I got to that I was like oh
this is all this makes it all worthwhile
this makes it all worthwhile because you
understand that after three years of war
this should be a notification to leaders
around the world that if you think that
you can't just order people and that's
gonna work out for you you're wrong
you're wrong and you know you said with
the way you were did something gotta
jump back to because you said you said
if you something like if you can't
explain to your people while you're
doing something then you're doing it
wrong I want to make it clear that when
you say you're doing it wrong you're
talking about what you're telling them
to do is wrong because if I can't if I
say hey Dave we want to assault this
target from the West and you're like why
and I say well because that's the best
spot and you go well there's a
channelized area we're gonna have to go
through and I say no we're gonna go from
the West and you say but there's an open
area here from the South where we can
get cover on this to high ground it will
be and I say no we're going from the
west and my only recourse is to say no
Dave I'm the boss you're going in from
the West you're doing it it wrong yeah
not just my beater ship you're doing the
thing that you're trying to get done is
wrong yeah so worthwhile
continues on it you got a look at the 44
like it's almost like here's the next
one after this in in 1941 it was all
troops assigned to the execution of a
distinct mission should be placed under
one command and the next the very next
line after they eliminate that all
troops assigned to the execution it's
literally the same they went through
this things like hey this this stuff
pretty solid
get rid of that line OOP what's her
growth down so check all troops assigned
to the execution of a distinct mission
should be placed under one command to
function as a task force for the
duration of the operation so long as a
commander can exercise effective command
he does not disturb the established
chain of command in his force in some
situations condition dictate that
attachments must be made to subordinate
commands so this is this is something
that see a little bit of this sometimes
you know like a on a group a task unit a
battalion a company gets assigned and if
the leader if the overall leader doesn't
have the wherewithal to say okay you
know what task unit bruiser you're
supporting and task unit alpha you're
you guys are running this and that's
asking a bruiser guy that's asking
bridge guys stay cool hey alpha what do
you need so often it's like man I should
have been the one made nests that should
be me and I remember a couple times
early and task unit bruiser while I was
trying to be if trying to hang out with
the fair ferry and be like well you know
I don't know it's like no Lafe you're
running this one Seth your support or
Seth you're running this one that's the
way it is I think I tried that one time
like only you guys gonna each being over
here no it's stupid and if your guys
actually believe in the mission it's no
factor it's never I don't care at all
Roger that boss I'm on it yeah what do
you need back and then if they get it
the big picture if you'd explain the
mission and they buy into it you could
put that guy as a support element
forever yeah and he's like a no factor
no matter what do you need I will
support all day long what do you need
not to mention half the time you go out
there and the situation completely
changes and the supporting effort
becomes the main effort of course of
course isn't it crazy though if you're
working for me and I go hey Dave you're
supporting effort and you're like
got it and then the next night I'm like
hey Dave you're supporting effort and
you're and you say awesome got it and I
say hey you know what you're gonna be
supporting effort again you're like
bring it I'm ready
we're getting this dialed and then I say
hey man I need you to do supporting
African and you say Roger that well we
ready so if that's your attitude that's
awesome
and eventually I go hey you know what
David you're running this that guest is
gonna be the main effort yeah now if I
go hey Dave you're the supporting effort
you go okay okay and then the next time
I go hey you're supporting effort again
why they were always supporting effort
last night I immediately hate you yeah I
immediately go bro is your ego really
that out-of-control they on this random
piece of paper of somewhere on this
particular operation on an operation
that we have no idea where it's gonna go
or what's gonna happen and you could end
up being the element that's in the big
giant firefight that needs to step up
and you want it you're so concerned
about that right now that's where your
priorities are that that's where we're
at okay cool noted I will never make you
I will never put you in charge of
anything ever yeah you know what nobody
ever asked me in 23 years of conducting
missions in the Marine Corps hey were
you assigned the main effort or either
supporter nobody cares and yeah it's
it's the blend of the ego and just hey
what's the best way to what's the thing
I can do to help accomplish the mission
I mean I don't care what it is and by
the way if you and I meet and I say hey
Dave you know I've been assigned
supporter you know to you which is kind
of crap because I think my company is
better than your company but whatever
that's what the boss decided so what
tell me what you need and I'll do it
like just think about that and now when
I say hey Dave you know we shouldn't do
it like that you will you won't listen
to a damn thing I say but if I say hey
Dave hey man we're here to support and
if you need anything tell me and let's
let's get it done and then we're an hour
into planning I go hey what do you think
about us setting up over here you know a
little bit different than your thoughts
but what do you think of that and you go
hmm well that's actually not a bad idea
mm-hmm so I have a little bit of
humility and all of a sudden I can
actually influence the situation a
thousand times more than if I go in
there with my chest
and my ego barking like a rabid dog yeah
and the worst part about that is if you
do that your idea might actually still
be better than mine and I won't listen
to your corner she's killing both of us
of course yeah it's just a freaking
disaster yeah just get on board for the
entire team to win and everything works
out get on board for the big win
estimate the situation in any tactical
operation the commander must have
quickly a value evaluate all available
information bearing on his task estimate
the situation and reach a decision the
commanders estimate the situation is
based on the mission of the unit the
means available to him and to the enemy
the conditions in his area of operations
including the terrain and whether the
probable effects of various lines of
action on future operations the basis of
these factors he considers the lines of
action open to him which if successful
will accomplish his mission and the
lines of action with of which the enemy
is physically capable and which can
interfere with such accomplishment he
analyzes the opposing lines of action
one against another to arrive at
conclusions as to the probability of
success for each of his own lines of
action it's a lot of words check all the
different courses of action see what the
potential outcomes are move forward with
one of them on the basis of this
analysis he can considers the relative
advantages disadvantages of his own
lines of action and selects the line of
action which most promises success
regardless of what the enemy may do if
two or more lines of action appear
equally promising he choose the one that
will most favored future action pretty
straightforward the estimate often
requires rapid thinking with
consideration limited to essential
factors in campaign exact conclusions
concerning the enemy can seldom be drawn
to delay action and emergency because of
insufficient information shows a lack of
energetic leadership and may result in
lost opportunities the commander must
take calculated risks
I read all that so I could say that last
thing
loulou strategic versus tactical if you
don't do anything in a tactical
situation you're gonna lose then you're
not gonna know everything no ever ever
you do not know the potential outcomes
even if you have the best intelligence
it's gonna change continue on
considering the enemy's possible lines
of action the commander must guard
against unwarranted belief that he has
discovered the enemy's intentions and
against ignoring other lines of action
open to the enemy this is what you said
earlier if you think you know what the
enemy's gonna do you're wrong don't
don't fall into that ego trapped even
when the weight of evidence warrants the
belief that the enemy is committed to a
definite line of action the commander
must bear in mind that a change in the
enemy's plans may occur at any time
that's the way it happens you got to
stay humble the estimate of the
situation culminates in the decision
once a decision a decision once made is
not changed without some compelling
reason in combat the will and energy of
the commander must persist until the
mission is accomplished
estimation of the situation is however a
continuous process and changed
conditions may at any time call for a
new decision she's too stubborn
adherence to a previous decision may
result in costly delay loss of
opportunity for decisive action or
outright failure so that the troop and
furin covered this very very well
sometimes yeah it's it's this you want
to stick with your plan but you're
constantly assessing to see if your plan
was the right plan if your decision was
the right decision and if it's not you
change you change that's the loop inputs
are happening all the time it's sooner
or later hey there's enough inputs tell
me I got to change I got to do some
different and you better have the
ability to maneuver when you're in that
when you're making those you made that
decision you're taking action you have
to preserve preserve the ability to
maneuver because it's going to change
period yeah that's that over commitment
it's
to talk about terrain here the part of
the commander's estimate dealing with
terrain often exercises decisive
influence upon his decision and plan the
proper evaluation and utilization of the
terrain reduced the disadvantage of
incomplete information of the enemy the
more important features to be considered
in evaluating terrain include not only
natural ground forms such as mountain
ridges streams bodies of water woods and
open spaces but also artificial features
such as roads railroads and towns the
commander seeks always to utilize the
terrain to his own advantage and to the
enemy's disadvantage now that's one of
those things where I was like yeah you
know what I definitely for me as a
leader when I would actually as a leader
but more as an instructor the difference
between like someone that sucks
as a small element unit leader small
unit leader someone that doesn't do it
right and someone that does it well is
someone that does it right utilizes the
terrain and someone that doesn't they
don't yeah
so that's why I put that in there but
there's much more to it than that and
that is the fact that when you are
leading people when you're interacting
with human beings
there's terrain that needs to be
accounted for the terrain isn't bridges
streams and mountains the terrain is ego
its agendas its personalities its
nuances that it's idiosyncrasies that
people have
that's the terrain that's so important
and it's that every single person you're
interacting with is going to be a little
bit different and those idiots agencies
and all those little small components a
good leader understands all of those
different things so the idea of what
terrain is in their mind is all of that
together yeah I I think you were setting
me up for a meeting and you gave me like
an eight-minute brief on the scenario
that was happening like hey this is
what's going on this is this guy this is
where he comes from this is what he
likes this is the problems he's had
here's where here's what I think he
wants
and this is the approach I would take
and I was like check what did you just
briefed me on you didn't mention
trails and mountains but you gave me the
terrain briefing I was about to walk
into that's what it is
and then then when I walk into that
meeting instead of me being a leader
that doesn't know what's happening all
of a sudden I'm a leader that
understands the terrain and can make the
right maneuvers know your terrain think
about what think about what and really
what this boils down to from a
leadership perspective in the business
world is think identify your terrain
right identify it let's let's let's talk
about what that is and see how we can
use it to our advantage next section is
called conduct in battle the commander's
decision for as unit as a whole and the
missions to subordinate units in support
of decision are communicated to
subordinates by clear and concise orders
which give them freedom of action
appropriate to their professional
knowledge to the situation to their
dependability and to the teamplay
desired so again I think there was a
Pogue in the room and sometimes the
other guys were like hey bro no freedom
of action is what these guys need and
and they just had to like sometimes add
this stuff while the Pogue was out
getting coffee
I think the Pogue was probably the
senior guy and a couple times he just
overrode them yeah but the Nate just
they just like he they sent him to get
they went to a meeting and they did like
several section that sentence is the
exact opposite of what that said yeah
you know a couple pages back it's exact
opposite thing freedom of action clear
and concise orders which gives them
freedom of action use that as your guide
next after providing for the issuance of
orders the commander places himself
where he can best control the course of
action and exert his leadership his
command post affords the advantage of
established signal communication when
opportunity offers and win his presence
at the command post is not urgently
required he visits subordinates
commanders and his troops in order to
inspire confidence and assure and to
assure himself
his orders are understood and properly
executed yep you got it the Navy they
started calling that deckplate
leadership did you guys ever hear that
say hey you need to get out you need to
get out with the troops you can't sit in
the door condition in space when you got
you know your your bosons mates down
there in the well deck right and it's a
hundred and eighty degrees in the well
back with diesel fumes yeah
whenever the commander leaves his
command post he should orient his staff
as to further plans to be made or
measures to be taken in anticipation of
future contingencies and should inform
his staff where he can be reached yep
during the decisive phase of battle the
place of the commander is near the
critical point of action not in it but
near it
a commander influences the course of
subsequent action by his leadership by
the use of his reserves by the
concentration of artillery and other
supporting fires and by the employment
of combat aviation and armored units the
duration of attack cooperation can
seldom be predicted successful
engagements engagements sometimes
progress so slowly that gains made are
not immediately apparent apparent other
times they progress so fast that gains
made can be capitalized only by the most
aggressive and farsighted leadership
troops are used up rapidly in decisive
phases of combat this attrition must be
anticipated by the commander and the
staff will take timely measures for
replacement of men units transports
weapons and for replenishment of
ammunition and other supplies when the
situation permits troops which have been
heavily engaged arrested and reorganized
before being assigned new and important
mission
the staff assists the commander to the
extent that he may require by providing
information data in advice by preparing
detailed plans and orders in accordance
with his direction that by exercising
such supervision over the execution of
his orders as he may prescribe a staff
officer as such does not exercise
command the staff may be divided into
two groups the general staff of the
special staff in large units these two
staff groups are separate and distinct
in smaller units they merge into each
other and one staff officer frequently
is charged with the duties pertaining to
both staff groups now have a whole
reason that I read the last two three
paragraphs was so I could read this in
every headquarters there is a constant
tendency to multiply personnel expand
the functions of staff administration
and accumulate records and office
equipment and then this is one of the
only thing that is italicized in this
book it says the commander must avoid
this expansion he must organize his
headquarters so as to maintain its
readiness for prompt movement so again
this is when the Pogue walked out of the
room there likely he the Pope wrote all
those other three tiers he was in all
right for staff this and their staff
commander and and then these guys were
like listen they're gonna try and expand
the staff get don't need it I was always
surprised like there's a section on the
staff yeah I was like oh do we need to
put that in and I and I've been
listening just even some of the other
things there's something that he said
earlier even about that at that point of
friction I think really what he was
saying is as you'll burn through
resources more quickly which is true I
understand that because that's where the
culminating event is and that that means
you know your people have to be cycled
through more quickly and you have to
pull them up there's a part of that
that's true for sure the point of
friction is going to require the most
resources and the most energy and you're
gonna exert yourself the most but
there's a piece in there that probably
needs to be worth expanding on a little
bit is that the point of friction is
actually if you're prepared and briefed
for it those people actually have the
most endurance because that's where they
want to be that's where they've been
anticipating being that's the entire
thing to say this
build has been about us to get there and
they're the most involved of the most
engaged those people also have the most
endurance it's the places where there's
the least amount going on it's the least
amount of friction where you feel you're
making the least impact those are the
people that are the first ones to really
struggle because they feel disconnected
and and I don't it's not a hundred
percent wrong the way they said it but I
wanted there to be a piece of saying oh
by the way everybody wants to be at the
point of friction on your team if you
prepared and built them and those people
can actually endure the longest you
still need to pull some of those folks
off the line you still need to assess
how they're doing but the people most
engaged are typically the people that
are most willing to stay engaged the
longest and that piece was missing in
that last section there is this there's
this piece time hint to all these
comments that are in there and like the
point of friction you would have to
choke me out to get me away from that to
give me a chance to rest and to refit
and and and again it doesn't mean that
you just let them go in the red forever
but there's just a part missing in there
that that this guy we're talking about
whoever this guy was a poke
yeah the pose and really RMF had a lot
of influence on that like yeah what
about the other part that says oh by the
way that's where everybody really wants
to be yeah because that guy doesn't want
to be there no and he's like all those
guys need a break like I dare you to
pull me off the line yeah when when
things are at their most intense good
luck getting me off the line the next
section is called combat orders the
authority to issue orders is an inherent
function of command orders are normally
issued to next subordinate commanders
bypassing the normal channels of command
is resorted only to in or urgent
situations it's such cases both
commander issuing that command the
commander receiving the order should
notify intermediate commanders of its
purport as soon as possible so try not
to jump the chain of command all orders
may be either complete or fragmentary
the order is complete when it covers all
the essential aspects of the phase of
phases of operations complete orders
include missions to all subordinate
units charged with the execution of
tactical operations in carrying out the
commander's plan so that's a complete
order fragmentary orders
and by the way there's no there's no
distinction between these two things in
grouping here oh so I think the Pogue
was like no orders have to be detailed
and the guys were like okay yep you're
Roger that sir but uh you know there's
something else that can happen maybe
possibly like we call them they made up
fragmentary orders fragmentary orders
are used when speed and delivery and
execution is imperative yeah
guess which one you're gonna do the most
yeah frag orders are issued successively
as the situation develops and as
decisions are made and consists of
separate instructions to one of four
subordinate units per scribe prescribing
each the part each is to play and the
operation in the separate phases thereof
this procedure will be usual in
divisions and smaller units that poke
snuck that one in there cuz it
fragmentary orders may be either oral or
written they are concise but not at the
expense of clarity and omission of
essential information that's very very
clear than they have in the in the upin
theorem instructions issued in
fragmentary orders may be repeated in a
complete field order or an annex of
considered desirable orders should be
originated sufficiently sufficiently
early and transmitted in such form as to
permit subordinate commanders the
maximum superior periods to reconnoiter
to estimate their own situations to
issue their orders and to prepare their
troops for the contemplated operation in
many situations it may be necessary or
desirable to order a warn of impending
operations warning order a warning order
contains information which which enables
subordinate commanders to make
preparations for a contemplated
operation its principal purposes to gain
the time for preparatory measures and to
conserve the energy of the troops so
that is in the troop infer the idea of a
warning order and warning orders are
awesome the be prepared to yeah here's
what we're probably going to do it's
gonna look something like this check
this gear think about that area of
operation
and if I was gonna take away something
from this that long section there if I'm
a leader in a business or a key leader
in an organization the takeaway for me
is it may feel like you at the top of
the org chart needs to talk the most
give the most information actually what
you should do is the map the time you
should maximize is your subordinators
going to figure out what they need to do
to support your overall mission the
least amount of information you can pass
it it has to be the right amount of
information but the more time you can
give them to figure out their particular
situation to support that the better
less talking more time for your people
to go dear their job as opposed to let's
get everybody in the room I'm gonna talk
all day long about every single detail
and not give them any time to go figure
out that's that's opposite so the Frago
and the warning oh that's probably 95%
of the way you're gonna communicate as
leader yeah once at your annual
conference for sure yeah we need to
spend some time we'll do that but that's
not gonna happen on day to day and the
West you talk is probably the better for
your team because it gives them more
time to lead yeah and those those
detailed plans are gonna change they're
gonna change yeah so you can you can if
you got if you
you've got the relationships and you've
got the well trained people and you've
got the trust built man the orders are
so frickin simply begin and now is the
thing with it and I didn't say this but
that's the whole jumping the chain of
command thing is what you really want
their time look don't jump the chain of
command if you can avoid it for sure
that's a good blanket statement but the
reality is is that are there time to
jump to chain yes there are and the best
thing I have when I jump the chain of
command is whoever that leader that I
bypass to give direct orders or
information to their folks if I got a
really good relationship in a long
history of them they don't even care and
there's no factor in oh I hate and I was
talking about hey Jacko you weren't
around and how to make this thing happen
this is what we did and while you're
like good to go coral sounds good it's
the pogue it's the guy who really likes
the chain of command tsuser you should't
bypass me to speak to my man is the guy
that who's most offended and it's
probably the hardest relationship
because what that guy cares about the
most is his positional Authority and
there's so much in there on even the
jump in the chain is you have good
you can jump the channel all day long
and I'm saying you should go out anyway
to do it but sometimes it's required and
strong relationships like yeah no factor
thanks for give me the heads up my guys
back briefed me anyway yeah we're all
good I'm all in yeah they told me what
they're doing got it appreciate it
thanks yeah no factor people that are
insecure about their leadership
capabilities are the ones that really
well that's the Lieutenant Colonel Paul
I think he's actually a colonel this
Polk colonel Polk ya know he's the
senior guy yeah yeah the senior guy and
yeah Colonel pogies in the house for
some of us orders an order should not
tres pot trespass upon the province of a
subordinate it should contain everything
that the subordinate must know to carry
out his mission but nothing more I
really like that order should not
trespass upon the province of a sabor
guess like you gotta let him run his
thing tell him what he needs and then
give him all the time in the world you
can't get let him go lead orders must be
clear and explicit and his brief as as
is consistent with clarity short
sentences are easily understood you know
they're like hey Colonel Colonel Polk do
you mind if we just say that short
sentences are easily understood because
some of the guys might not get that he's
like whoa I'd like to talk to you about
that for a while
clarity is more important than technique
the more urgent the situation the
greater the need for conscious for
conciseness in the order think about
that the more urgent the situation the
greater the need for conciseness in the
order I think it was Mark Twain that
said I wanted to write you a short note
but I didn't have time so I'm writing
you this long letter which is easier
than writing something short and concise
I come back you tell the story a lot on
the podcast and it's the bus that door
just the three with just this the
simplest and the reason you have to say
it like that is because there's actually
not
any more time than you need to talk
about hey well I feel like the enemy
might be maneuvering this bust that door
and they go and they go do that no and
then problem solved
totally any statement of reasons for
measures adopted should be limited to
what is necessary to obtain an
intelligent cooperation from the
subordinates I'm Reed that want again
any statement of reasons for measures
adopted should be limited to what is
necessary to obtain intelligent
cooperation from the subordinates
there's a little bit there's a little
argument about that one because the the
Polk colonel Polk was like you need to
do you tell me what to do and the other
guys like listen you need to give them
some information on why this is
happening and he's like no you don't and
they said yes you do and finally they
wrote this statement a compromise yeah
the compromise is like at least let them
know give them what's limited so that
they have have the information and can
understand why it's happening now there
are times when leaders give too much
information and it overwhelms the
machine gunner who's like bro tell me
what my field of fire is for sure he
tell me that again detailed instructions
for a variety of contingencies or
prescriptions that are a matter of
training do not inspire confidence and
have no place in an order trivial and
meaningless expressions divide
responsibility and lead to the adoption
of half measures by subordinate by
subordinates trivial and meaningless
expressions so they're actually telling
you how to write and how to speak yeah
tree V trivial and meaningless
expressions divide responsibilities and
lead to the adoption of half measures by
subordinates exaggerated and bombastic
phrases invite ridicule and weaken the
force of an order you cannot do that you
cannot use exaggerated and bombastic
phrases what's what what happens is you
think you're not getting the message
apart
dear people yeah you think that they
don't get it if we don't do this it's
gonna destroy the company and you're
thinking that go I'd better pay
attention and all that does is just
undermine your message like bro yeah
hang hang on that it's not going to
destroy the company if you're the leader
that that if you can have this you know
didn't recognize you're the one that
covers all these little detail points
your people are tuning you out they're
tuning you out and actually what's gonna
happen is they're gonna miss the
important things so you just need to say
just the important things yeah what you
do is you paint yourself into a corner
totally because if you're talking and
you're saying this and then you're
saying that and then you're saying this
and then you're saying that and then you
finally want to say something important
you want to make sure everyone pays
attention so you put an exaggeration or
you make it a bombastic phrase and then
what your end up doing is now you're
making exaggerations and in bombastic
phrases all the time and they have no
impact and you're the you end up the the
boy that cried wolf last musters
somebody asked you a question and the
answer was basically kind of like how
much talking how much listening and
you're like 98 percent listening two
percent talking and you pause you're
like now that I've thought about it
that's the perfect ratio it's just the
least amount of things you can say to
pass the print information and then stop
talking and if it's the the only way to
compel your people to do it is that the
risk is total destruction then the one
in a million times that actually it
could be total destruction they actually
don't respond the way that they need to
they don't care because you've been
saying it this could crush us
this could destroy us like the one time
that's that's true they filtered you out
years ago yeah yeah ninety-eight percent
of the time use your ears two percent of
the time use your mouth I I would not
talk on the radio in task unit bruiser
as a platoon but I would not talk on the
radio when I talked everybody listens
totally and same thing you know when
when one up attune commanders are given
a brief I'm not talking I got three
things to say at the end maybe two
here's what's important that's what you
need to think about boom
expressions such as attack vigorously if
used in orders are not only verbose and
meaningless but tend to weaken the force
of subsequent orders in which such
expressions in official that's exactly
what you were just saying like you're
gonna run out of adjectives yeah it is
critically important yeah yeah there's
the hierarchy of adjectives and you're
gonna reach the end of it which is gonna
suck next orders should prescribe only
so far as conditions can be foreseen
orders which attempt to regulate matters
too far in the future result in frequent
changes frequent changes in orders
overload the means of signal
communication cause confusion and
misunderstanding impose needless
hardship on the troops and injure their
morale so there you go that's frickin
epic right there totally you you sit
there and you're trying to what I just
said this dip we're gonna come out with
a detailed plan of how it's gonna go
from day one to day 19 no no you're not
you're not no one is and it it pisses
your guys off for sure this is them oh
sure I learned this lesson so I was on a
argot deployment which meant I was on a
ship and we were planning for some
mission and at first they said okay
you're gonna launch from you're gonna
launch from the boats the the rib boats
the rigid hull inflatable boats you load
your zodiacs on there it will put it in
the water and you guys will go do your
mission and so we start prepping for
that and then they come back and they
say actually sorry
our bust you're gonna use helicopters so
we're like okay now this is a totally
different rigging exercise I mean
completely different we have to yet so
we have to bring the zodiacs which we
had rigged for boat launch we had to
completely break them down and now rig
them to go inside of a ch-46 and get
kicked out the back and then we jump in
the water we go this takes us I'm not
even kidding this takes six hours of
hard labor and our five and a half comes
back actually you're not using helos
you're using boats again
and there was like borderline just total
breakdown of
chain-of-command me because because
guess what we hadn't planned anything we
hadn't done any of our personal beer
purple all we were doing was and and
when you're on an argh
like you you go check out bringing a 55
horsepower engine from the flight deck
next to the ribs down into the well deck
you know and then you do that with every
piece of gear that you have well it was
just stupid and and of course this was a
three minute converse is a decision a
three minute conversation and a four
second decision that my upper chain of
command above my platoon commanders you
know was like oh it'd be good to get him
some work and not in the helos okay well
yeah let's get the helos going have him
get ready for a helo it wasn't like okay
are they committed no they just made a
little decision and and I learned that
in that moment in time when you're the
guy in charge you better know what the
hell your decisions yeah how your
decisions impact it was because not look
was it hard work yes but was even worse
than the fact that was hard work we were
not prepared now we had wasted it took
us another six hours to get everything D
rigged so we were not planning the way
we should have been planning because we
were running around like idiots wasting
time wasting time orders issued by
subordinates should not be mere
repetition of those from higher
authority with additions of their own
new orders are clearer and more
satisfactory as a rule it is desirable
to keep contemplated operation secret as
long as possible and to confine
knowledge thereof to new to few staff
officers and senior commanders however
upon entry into action no unit should be
in doubt as to what the commander wants
to do whenever knowledge of his
intentions is necessary to ensure the
cooperation of units engaged the
commander does not hesitate to disclose
them to all concerned ignorant of his
intentions may often lead to inactivity
on the poorest on the part of
subordinates commander's intent
is the actual thing that you lead with
it's the most important piece of
information of all of it
and when we work with companies all the
time there's this phrase that people
know it's like if you ever hear yourself
or the people around you're saying you
don't need to know that just do your job
man the likelihood of success is
basically zero Jack it is impossible to
prescribe detailed forms of orders to
fit every tactical situation to attempt
to do so would result in rigid 4 in a
rigid form and a routine style of
expression which would not be in accord
with that in accord with the tactical
requirements presented by the diverse
situations that arise in war you don't
know what's gonna happen that circles
back I think to the first sentence you
read and words like you can't script the
answer you don't know what's going to
happen to the extent practicable however
it has been found efficient and
convenient to classify combat orders
according to their purpose and scope of
for some of these to adopt a standard
sequence of composition this makes for
the ease of understanding avoidance of
emissions and ready references yeah for
sure that's where you get Smith which
they surprisingly don't cover they cover
it in through pandering but they don't
cover it in this one but that's what
they're talking about
moreover experience has shown that an
order which can be misunderstood will be
misunderstood and the experience has
shown that in order that which can be
misunderstood will be misunderstood and
to obviate the designations of
boundaries details of time and place
military terminology abbreviations
designations of units and the like for
details related to these matters
CFM 101 TAC 5 and I wrote TAC 1 which is
the operational turns in graphics which
in the SEAL Teams when the war kicked
off we were not we didn't know what we
were doing like in terms of operational
terms and graphics we just kind of drew
arrows yeah and like made it obvious to
the guys in the platoon like hey move
there bad guys there we didn't we didn't
realize that there was an actual
an actual language that was utilized
throughout all like I remember when I
was trying to convince people that the
entire military well it's through it's
not just through our military it's all
NATO forces by the way because I
remember having I would be like hey
listen you know you need to put this
stuff in here there's this manual it's
called the one along tack file I used to
literally have the one on one tack five
tack one I had a printed copy and I had
it in my bathroom I had like one copy in
my bathroom and I would read through it
you know because at some point I think I
was probably I think I was probably a
platoon commander and I realized like oh
everyone uses this but us okay so I just
started trying to learn terms and you
know cuz we don't have the basic school
in the SEAL Teams we don't even have you
know advanced infantry training like
they have in the army where you're gonna
you you you go through platoon work but
it's this isolated thing right it's this
isolated thing and luckily I did two art
deployments where we worked at the
Marine Corps extensively which was
awesome and I got my taste and my
indoctrination in how the rest of the
freakin military works cuz you got big
Navy you got the Marine Corps he got
Marine Corps Air it was awesome I was so
lucky that I got put in those situations
and that's kind of where I first would
see these things I'd be like oh that's
an interesting symbol but you know it
was pre-internet it wasn't like you
could it wasn't like I could explore
this idea but yeah I used to have one of
those next to my bet but I remember
trying to tie would be telling guys like
hey the symbol for the enemy actually
isn't a red X it's it's a diamond yeah
that's and they'd be like no no one's
gonna know what that means
actually everyone in NATO forces knows
what that means the only people that
don't know is the sixteen guys in your
seal platoon how about we get on board
with what everyone else in the military
is doing Jack and now we get this is the
last section that's you know that's
that's covered
worth covering in every unit standing
operating procedures is prescribed by
the commander wherever practicable this
procedures covers those features of the
operation which lend themselves to a
definite or standardized procedure
without loss of effectiveness the
adoption of such procedures will save
time in the preparation and issuance of
orders minimize the chances for
confusion and errors when under stress
of combat and greatly simplify and
expedite the execution of operations in
the field pretty straightforward and
they close out talking about command
posts which nothing they talk about
signal communication which you know this
is very tactical level stuff like how
you're gonna communicate at during this
time period with with message centers in
advance mess I mean it's it's like the
actual how they're doing it so mmm it's
not super applicable other than the
stuff that we've already covered about
things being simple clear and concise I
mean literally airplane messengers may
be employed when distance intervening
obstacles on the ground and other
factors preventing use of other means so
that's what it's talking about it is
actually talking to take it one step
further homing pigeons are a mean of
communication from front to rear when
other means excel so that's where I'm
not gonna dive into all those things
even though they are interesting and
fascinating and we can I'm sure learn
something but we're not gonna dive too
deep so that's that's kind of where it
wraps up and as I mentioned before the
the 1944 version if you look at that the
the other than the differences than what
I pointed out there's an entire big
section of air power and and how you
utilize it and then there's more
granular tactics but again we're taught
it's a little bit homing pigeon fish you
know not not readily applicable as
leaders but the but the leadership
principles the other than that one
sentence that we pointed out other than
that one sentence it's almost it doesn't
change and it's very similar to
the troop and furor which is very
similar to everything that we talk about
all the time good leadership requires
understanding people good leadership
means you have to care about your men
you have to as the book says show a
constant concern for their comfort and
welfare how about you make that a
priority as a leader you can't
unnecessarily tax the endurance of the
troops discipline is the main cohesive
force in a unit good morale cannot be
improvised and and finally through
offensive action through offensive
action the commander exercises his
initiative preserves his freedom of
action and imposes his will on the enemy
that's what we need to do is go on the
offense on all fronts don't wait for
orders don't wait for the Intel to be
perfect and if you have to be on the
defense don't stay there look for that
moment in time where you can flip the
scenario go on the offense take ground
move forward and impose your will on the
enemy and yes that does translate to
business and it certainly translates to
what you do with your life get go on
offense when you wake up in the morning
that's what you do don't wait to react
you'll end up on the defense and you
will eventually get taken out
and I think that's all I got for this
one anything else
crazy isn't it dude so good man
somebody will reach out to me and tell
me who wrote this yeah
that's what's gonna happen yeah somebody
will reach out to me somebody reached
out to me I've got a track on the FM one
TAC three I've got a master I think it's
a master gunnery sergeant that was in
the room who is a Vietnam guide yeah
who's like oh you know it's I I want to
say his son
I think his son reached out to me hey
just kind of f1 maybe it was one of the
guys who served with him hey just FYI
you know this guy was in the room had a
big park riding it and you know if you
want to ask him some questions I'm like
uh 100% unfortunately since Colonel
Pogue was probably 48 years old when he
was doing this we won't get him in the
room we don't need him in the room no
you know the timing of that when you
certainly when you look at the timing
when they're written I mean the takeaway
you think about is you learn the hardest
lessons from the most difficult
situations and you learn the hardest
lessons from the most challenging
environments with your team and just
think about how different the world was
from 1920 to 1940 and then from 1941 to
1943 oh yeah and even if you looked at
if you had a closed mind and you were
looking at World War one even if even if
Colonel Pope served in World War Y what
he took away from that was like listen
when I say charge there's just problems
there's people that don't charge when I
say charge that's horrible
he might have been in that eclis saying
listen obedience is the most important
thing and there are some guys that were
came back and you know when he said it
the first time they were like well hey I
know you were a platoon commander but
like I was he over here and we actually
needed to think about what we were doing
then after three years of war they just
shut him down and said hey the methods
that you used in World War one sucked
and if we would have trained our troops
to say
boss that's a dumb idea we should not
get up and charge this we should not go
and online at zero six hundred when the
when the bugle sounds I'm not doing it
and we should not do it should not do
this because we are going to lose four
hundred and eighty men when that bugle
sounds and that's stupid yeah because
we're gonna get nothing cuz we're gonna
get nothing out of it
and so that's what we want and that's
what this whole book begs for at least
at least that at least the the the other
guys in the room beg for people who
think that's what they beg for use your
initiative question your boss your boss
can't explain why we're doing something
then he's doing it wrong and a leader
who has subordinates put that push back
new hey boss hey I don't get this I
don't think this is right that's the
best leadership you couldn't have it I
want my guys to go hey hang on I don't
understand this
that's the best feedback I could
possibly get which is them saying
timeout I don't understand we need to
keep talking about this as opposed to
one of two things sort of there's this
blind loyalty or they just do whatever I
say cuz there's no way I've got it all
right or worse they think this guy's an
idiot and it's not even worth talking to
him about it how disconnected those are
two are you if you're a leader you want
your people pushing back you want them
asking you hard questions and if you
can't answer their questions you have
more work to do yeah yeah and and if
you're smart the ones that you will
charge with answering those questions is
those men themselves that are asking
them because if they say why are we
coming in from the West you say well I
thought it looked good please tell me
why you don't think that's gonna work go
do a better map study than I did by the
way cuz I got three other elements that
I'm looking at but cool you come up with
a better plan please we're standing by
for that so yeah these these principles
of combat man
these principles of leadership they just
don't change and it's so it's crazy that
in 2019 right now you and I can work
with leaders you and I can meet leaders
that are 100% aligned with Colonel Pogue
yeah they're 100% aligned with Colonel
poke their attitude is listen hey what I
want is people just do what I tell them
to do and god that sounds good doesn't
it this sounds great
hey if these guys just do what I told
them do here's the problem you're not
that freakin smart you don't even know
what they should do how can you you
don't know the front lines you're not
seeing what's happening you're not in
that manufacturing you're not on that
line you're not on that construction
site you're not in that in that meeting
you're you're you're supposed to be
looking up and out so how can you know
what's going on down there you don't let
your people lead all right
so speaking of going on offense we kind
of want to go on offense in our lives I
think that's a smart thing to do trained
jiu-jitsu trained jiu-jitsu how many
things you will be able to relate to
jiu-jitsu is infinite it's gonna make
you better leader it's gonna make you a
better boss it's gonna make you better
follower it's gonna make you a better
dad make you better mom make you a
better human being and hopefully get
your kids doing it too it's gonna help
them even more get them in the game so
yeah Jitsu if you need you to do ki then
get one from a place called origin
origin main com where we're not just up
there selling DS or what we're doing is
up there bringing manufacturing back to
America that's what we're doing that's
where it belongs highest quality it
supports this podcast if you like this
podcast just go to origin and get
something that supports the podcast but
more important like I said it supports
the United States of America
it supports the community up there
that's what we're doing
so origin main you can get t-shirts you
can get joggers which I personally don't
worry but I got I got to say up hoodies
and jeans
by the way jeans best jeans ever do you
ever wear jeans Dave I cannot remember
the last time I wore jeans I know that's
I just wear shower shorts all of the
time when I lived in Virginia my
criteria for shorts is it had to be
below freezing so when you get a gig in
New York City in January and you're
flying out there what are you where on
the point shorts really shorts and a
national on front t-shirt or a origin
Maine t-shirt I might bring a hoodie if
I think it's gonna be chilly check so a
hundred percent your honor shorts 100%
now here's here's here's one up I left a
little caveat okay
so 99% guess what I don't have yet I'll
tell you what so that's that's I'm sorry
you know I see what you're doing so
right now we have the heavyweight jeans
and they're not they're not heavy we're
gonna have your weight then they're just
normal jeans I got jeans right now that
are light weight jeans and they're
freaking the best things ever
all right there is one thing that will
push me off the 100% shorts that's the
one yeah so that's my can we got the
material in its you know made in America
woven of grown in America so anyways the
up jeans the I'm gonna call I think the
the name of the jeans is gonna be mekong
68 because if you don't know this the
Vietnam SEALs my forefathers the people
that gave me everything I have today in
the Mekong Delta of Vietnam the fatigues
that we were that the seals were issued
weren't durable enough for the
operations that they were doing so they
wore blue jeans and so mekong 68
jeans and also we got boots
we got origin boots they're awesome
handmade in Maine check them out they're
ready for pre-order right now so order
some and then we got supplements join
water fair krill oil discipline
discipline go and then we've got
discipline ready to drink which is gonna
shock the world dude so you had some
discipline go pill before this podcast
yes I was looking at you cuz I did too I
was looking at you know I was like we
are connected I was like I I hear what
you're putting out on that yeah so you
get all those good supplements you get
Mulkey and your warrior kid milk
strawberry chocolate mint whatever the
best stuff in the world yes no sugar you
you would swear that it's sweetened with
sugar yep but it's not it's miraculous
and then chocolate white tea so good so
good it's been a hot summer into in San
Diego California and I've been burning
through the jock of white tea in a can
so all those things all good to go and
then we have another store called Jocko
store where you can get rash guards
t-shirts hats hoodies whatever a bunch
of stuff on there if you wanna as echo
Charles says if you want to represent
while you're on the path he seems to
think that gets the the message across
he could be right we don't know he might
be right there's some evidence out there
I saw on Twitter the other day a guy
posted something that his wife said hey
you got a birthday coming up
is there anything you want and his
answer was we have a store it's called
John Kerr store and that was his answer
to is why I say the woods get out there
that is legit Jocko has a store it's
called jaha store that's what uh echo
usually says about that to subscribe to
the podcast wherever you subscribe to
podcasts leave a review so I can read
your review and be a entertained or be
in
formed about your critique points so
that's good
echo seems to think people don't
subscribe so maybe it's hard to get
people to subscribe to a podcast because
they think it fills up their phone or
something I don't know but anyways if
you don't scratch crap also check out
the warrior kid podcast we are working
always to try and get more warrior kid
podcast done because I know parents are
mad at me when I don't release them yes
because they listen to the same podcast
I think there's 23 of them right now
there's 23 yeah I think it's 23 so I oh
I try and put him out in threes for some
reason I don't even know why I have one
in the bank I'll do two more sorry but
check it out and then get some warrior
Kid soap Irish Oaks ranch calm Aiden he
sold his thousandth package the other
Doria thousand he's I think he's 13 now
but you know he's just getting after it
so stay clean Irish Oaks French comm
YouTube channel there's a YouTube
channel you can subscribe to you can see
what Dave Burke looks like you can see
what I look like you can see us laughing
and carrying on you can see our
expressions you can see what we look
like when we're talking about Colonel
poke my new arch enemy in the world
and you can see echoes completely overly
enhanced videos where things are blowing
up it's the worst overuse of special
effects walls are being smashed walls
are being smashed things are exploding
but a lot of people like them including
echo psychological warfare if you need
that little little a little shot in the
brain if you need it you can get a
psychological warfare on iTunes
mp3 platforms of all kinds flipside
canvas calm
that's Dakota Meyers company and he's
making shot in the arm that you can hang
on the wall that's what it is it's a
shot in the arm that you can hang on the
wall so you wake up every morning you
can see something that says discipline
equals freedom
I got some books the next book to come
out is called leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual you can pre-order
it right now if you want the first
edition I was talking to my publisher
the other day and we're talking about
what to do
I said listen my people there they want
the first dish and I want them to know
that they got the first dish so we're
gonna do something I'm not a hundred
percent sure yet but something to
indicate at least that's the plan
something to indicate that you got that
first two dish so you get one chance to
be on the first dish train and then
you're forever well I guess you could
buy a used one for thousands of dollars
off of ebay if you miss the hit if you
missed the initial first a dish train
and you don't wanna let that happen so
so leadership strategy and tactics
really break down this stuff on a
granular level on how to apply it in
specific situations that you're in
pre-order that one now way the warrior
kid there's three of them the most
recent is where there's a will your
daughter it seems to be mega on the path
right yeah I mean you got to be so proud
dude she is dialed in man um I'm I'm
still can and we actually were talking
about it the other day
she is she had to write a little letter
all the kids in that started school they
had to write a little bio about
themselves and kind of put up on the
wall to introduce themselves to the
class and inside that biography it was
talking about things that are important
to you what he thinks you like she used
the phrase discipline she used the
phrase ownership she said good people
don't make excuses I didn't even know
she wrote it so I went to back-to-school
night a couple weeks ago and I read it
took a picture of it I'm like man this
kid is so far ahead of where I was at
that age it's uncle Jake's been a good
influence in her life
uncle Jake he has lessons for everyone
but the problem is kids don't listen to
their parents like they listen to Uncle
Jake oh it's just the way it is yes my
own kids don't listen to me as much as
they listen to Uncle Jake
that's just the way it is yeah they're
programmed to rebel against you they
have to otherwise they'll be living at
home when there are 38 years old you
don't want that you want them to rebel
against you but when they look outside
for guidance you want them to find the
right guidance there's Uncle Jake
standing at a rigid parade rest ready to
put out the word and if you're a parent
you've now know and you're listening you
now know you have those resources
available to you because if you're like
most parents when your kid rebels you
know what most of us do we squash that
which is the worst thing you can do for
summer when I push them away further and
now you can say hey look I understand
and now you've got some other you got
some flanking maneuvers you can
implement and have them because they're
gonna think they're figured out on their
own which in some ways they are but the
reason they're even getting there in the
first place is because of you that's
legit so way the warrior kid one two and
three
the first one's called away the warrior
kid the second one's marks mission the
third one is where the word could
through where there's a will got Mikey
and the Dragons you gonna be like I just
had this when I was on with you of on
this guy had he had called in the last
time and had a kid on the way
he was super freaked out and scared and
he was like what should I do and you
know it's like okay here's a plan to go
forward and then we called him yesterday
called the guy back and he's like yeah I
got the kid and it's not as bad as I
thought it was gonna be in fact it's
actually amazing and I was like yeah
those dragons are small this dragons
aren't as big as you think they're gonna
be so Mike in the dragon teach your kids
to overcome teach your kids to stand up
teach your kids to understand what fear
is and how they can actually react to it
in a positive way Mikey in the dragons
get that book for kids that you know man
that's another book I wish I had when I
was little this women's freedom Field
Manual how to get after it
yes you need that manual that's another
one you what do you need to redo that a
day
read one page read one page and
calibrate your brain for the day that's
what it is
brain calibration calibrate your brain
one page a day it'll take you three
minutes to read and you'll be crowd
calibrated and then of course there's
the two books that I wrote with my
brother lave Bab and extreme ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership talking
about all the things that we've been
talking about today leadership how to
lead what to look out for how to
overcome those obstacles we have a salon
front which is our leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership all of your
problems are leadership problems that's
what we do Dave Burke got him got Andrew
Paul who's on last time it's it's it's
all of us that's what we do we do it 24
hours a day seven days a week we are
working with companies and then on top
of that we have EF online which is its
interactive training online where you
can learn the leadership principles that
we talk about look the books are are
great the podcast boom is a great income
to the muster all these things are good
none of them work alone no you you want
to give yourself as many advantages as
possible get on EF online.com and learn
these leadership principles deeper more
granular leadership is a skill
it requires reps reps after reps after
reps musters an awesome rep this podcast
is an awesome rep the books are awesome
reps EF online gives you an unlimited
number of reps to go get and you need to
get reps when you're learning leadership
period speaking of the muster the next
one we're doing is in Sydney Australia
the other two sold-out Chicago sold-out
Denver sold-out Sydney's going to sell
out extreme ownership calm if you want
to come and when it sells out there's no
caveats Denver was sold out via no
additional seat
yeah and the you've got fire marshals
like it's not like we can bend the rules
sorry we can't put people at risk
because they want to come to the muster
that's not the way it works so if you
want to come we're looking forward to
coming on down to Australia and getting
after it with you all and of course we
have EF overwatch now which is we're
taking proven leaders from the spec ops
community the combat aviation community
and we're placing them into companies
that need to implement all these
leadership principles that we're talking
about you don't need somebody that knows
your industry what you need is someone
that knows how to leave they'll figure
out your industry trust me they they
know how to adapt and overcome they will
get there and get in the game if you
want that go to EF over watch.com and if
you want to continue this discussion
with us which I can promise you Dave and
I spend a lot of time together when we
do spend time together
or I shouldn't say we spend a lot of
time together when we spend time
together because we're on the road a lot
when we spend time together did we talk
about leadership all the time that's all
we just talked about just talk about
leadership so if you want to talk about
leadership with us cool you can find us
on the interwebs Twitter Instagram do
fossum book Dave is that Dave Burke
David's at David are Burke and I am at
Jacques are willing Dave any closing
thoughts on this one
yeah one parting thought you're going
through the books anytime I'm on the
podcast which is completely awesome I
get a lot of hits on social media asking
me about the eminently qualified human
being
Roger 174 174 podcast 174 let me tell
you why you don't have that yet is
because I simply haven't done a good
enough job getting it done it is close
but I am NOT doing my job we are getting
very close that is coming out soon I
will I will finish that project and I
will get that done
what about the app
we are we finished an awesome beta test
and thank you for all of you out there
they were dialed in on that we are
closed on that as well
and what you're gonna see pretty soon is
the app getting released and hopefully a
digital version of that but you guys are
asking the questions the answer is I'm
just not doing a good enough job it's
coming soon the interesting thing about
and I know this would when I said this
to you you were like what and I was like
hey well we'll get an app out you know
we can build an app and release that
like as soon as soon as possible and
you're like well wouldn't it be easier
to like just print to publish a book and
I'm like nope believe it or not it's an
archaic system and we're not I don't
know we're not a hundred percent certain
of how we're gonna roll that out but the
priority is speed right the priority of
getting the eminently qualified human
being app and document book which we've
also well which we've we've actually we
actually see weeks we had a little
mission creep right a little mission
creep because as I'm looking at it I'm
thinking hey this is cool this is
awesome but guess what there's some
protocols that we could give people guru
yeah it grew so now we've got some
protocols in there for kind of standard
operating procedures for things that go
down in your life and they're really
good they I didn't have that big picture
vision we started working on it but
we've had some folks can should be to
that a lot of a lot of things have gone
into it it's certainly bigger but it
it's it's actually where it needs to be
yeah it's pretty close right now
dude it's close man we got to just get
out there okay cool so that's that and
obviously once again we would not even
be sitting in this room at all if it
were not for our brave and courageous
military men and women around the world
so thanks to all of you that have served
and those that are currently serving
thank you and the same goes to our
police and law enforcement the
firefighters out there the paramedics
the EMTs the dispatchers the
correctional officers the Border Patrol
the Secret Service to all the first
responders
once again without you we cannot live
the life that we live here so thanks to
all of you for what you're doing and to
both your families that are supporting
that are sacrificing thanks to your
families as well and to everyone else
out there life is a war right it is a
war that's what it is
at least at a minimum it's a metaphor
for a war it's a fight and there are
people out there and there are things
out there that are trying to take you
down there is friction and there are
obstacles and there is complacency and
you might think when I say life's war
like well not really but check this out
listen to me in this situation that
you're in your life is at stake your
life is actually at stake right now
what you do with your life is at stake
you are fighting for your life every day
the way that you live it the mark that
you're gonna leave the legacy that
you're gonna leave the people that you
help the people that you help the people
that you can help move forward the
people that are weak that you can make
stronger all that is gonna come back to
you that is your life and your life is
at stake
right now every day almost as if you are
at war so don't sit back and be on the
defense and allow life to happen to you
don't do that instead go on the offense
every day by getting up and getting
after it and until next time this is
Dave Burke and Jocko Oh